[Music]
so
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
if you're in love happy valentine's day
if you're not
in love well better luck next time if
you're chinese
kung hi fa choi happy new year if you're
chinese and you're in love
what are you doing watching this show
you are going to have a good night
but for everyone else we're very glad
that you're joining us tonight because
with one bound he was free well
as well as you can bound with the bone
spurs problem
and all of that donald trump has walked
free from the second impeachment trial
over the last four years he has been
impeached more times than anyone else
but he's been cleared
by the court of the senate more than
anyone else will he run again in 24
or will he find someone with fresh legs
no bone spurs in his own family to
run on his behalf with him as the kind
of
godfather did i say godfather and we'll
be talking about
boris johnson his alter ego here
in london who has done a good thing
he's announced a tunnel from stran raar
in southwest scotland to learn in north
east ireland bringing the two islands
physically together
for the very first time i'm wholly in
favor of it myself
for lots of reasons which i shall adam
break
if anyone is interested and i got the
coronavirus job
not the russian not the chinese i got
the pfizer
i stiffened up immediately if you get my
drift
it's going to be rock and roll radio
with pictures so fasten your seat belts
it's the mother of all talk shows
radio sputnik we speak your language
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free
[Music]
george galloway this
is radio sputnik
and this is london but coming to you of
course all over the world thanks to the
wonders of the internet
and sputniknews.com if you're in
washington dc
as donald trump is no more but might
now yet be again you can listen in
crystal clarity on fm
105.5 fm are the magic numbers there
wherever you are in i don't know key
largo
in florida or anywhere from burning city
to burning city
right across the united states you can
listen
on am you can listen all over the world
on the aforementioned
sputniknews.com but if you are one of
the
more than half a million people who now
every week watch as well as listen to
the show please
listen to this mr algorithm is
always active and he's always trying
to choke off our numbers last week on
facebook we ended the show
with 60 000 viewers within a couple of
days we were
160 000 viewers go figure
how did that happen best way to avoid it
happening
is right now if you're watching on
facebook to share
share share with all of your friends all
of your contacts on
facebook you can watch of course on my
own facebook page
do follow me there if you can
and you can watch on the facebook pages
of
rt the multitude actually of facebook
pages of
rt ditto on youtube if you're watching
on my youtube channel
don't forget to subscribe but you can
also watch on the youtube channels
of rt a multitude of those
you can also watch on your phone on
twitter
as a truly remarkable number of people
are now doing
you can watch on twitch i think
there may be others my friends will tell
me but
we are reaching more and more of the
world through
more and more platforms because you
never know when that algorithm
is going to get nasty now
with one bound as i said uh a limp
really donald trump walked free it was
a waste of taxpayers dollars and
the united states time especially when
they have so many pressing problems
to attend to the economy is in free fall
the coronavirus pandemic murderously
wiping out
record numbers you remember when they
thought that uh
200 000 dead would be
an outcome they could if you'll forgive
the pun
live with well it is rampant
in the united states still until now
rampant joe biden didn't fix it after
all his mask idea
hasn't yet begun to work it may
of course speaking as someone who wears
a mask
i don't in any way want to discourage it
but the idea that everything in the
united states would be rosy once
the orange man was out of the white
house is already
if you forgive another pun looking
pretty lame
the democrats promised in fact they
promised on the eve of paul
in the crucial georgia senatorial
by-elections
vote for us and you'll get two thousand
dollars
call it bribery if you like but that's
what they said
but they didn't actually mean it they
meant
you'll get fourteen hundred dollars uh
and if you add the six hundred dollars
you got
one year ago from donald trump well
that'll
add up to two thousand dollars
even though it's only fourteen hundred
it still
has not been paid and the united states
has not
rejoined the jcpoa the iran nuclear deal
that's another pre-election promise at
least not fulfilled if
not broken yet in fact they've laid down
a number of conditions
which mean that it's exceedingly
unlikely
that the united states will be rejoining
the iran nuclear deal
so much for those that voted for joe
biden
because that's the outcome that they
wanted
the chance therefore of war between the
united states and iran
continues to be considerable red alert
if you are an iranian after all all that
far
power in the persian gulf what's it
there for
joe biden ain't going to recall the
troops in fact he's doubling
down sending more troops to iraq
and cancelling the withdrawal
of forces from places like afghanistan
we'll be talking
to literally the one and only dr chris
hedges the amanda in
any normal polity would be the secretary
of state
running the foreign affairs of the
united states
instead he's here talking to us on the
mother of all talk shows lucky
lucky us and we'll be talking about
relationships well it is saint
valentine's day i've actually
seen the casket in which the bones of
saint valentine
repose i don't know if you know this
but the bones of saint valentine himself
repose in glasgow i can't remember the
name of the church but i went there to
frank
mcelhon's funeral if someone can remind
me
and uh the late cardinal tom winning
presiding and uh before
the funeral i went and i saw the bones
of saint valentines he was actually
martyred bludgeoned
to death his head was cut off
i'm not sure how all that morphed into
us
sending each other flowers and
chocolates not that i got either flowers
or chocolates i got absolutely nothing
for valentine's day did you you can let
me know
i'll be talking to joe barna who's a
relationship
expert a dating expert so if you
are in the dating game you better listen
to what she
has to say did i tell you i got my
vaccination i got the pfizer vaccination
on friday i'm that old and i got it
thanks to the british
army in scotland
in fact all the soldiers were english
i almost wanted to apologize to them
for the hideous hateful rhetoric
that they have to put up with in
scotland under the snp and unrelenting
barrage
a real barrage of hate
from scottish nationalists on twitter
and who knows maybe even on the street
the injection was absolutely
flawlessly delivered i literally
did not feel it and i've had no side
effects
touch wood no sore arm
no headache no
fever and i'm already three days in
i will have to wait 12 weeks to get the
second job
but i'm looking forward to that and i
want to
encourage everybody to get this
vaccination it will be better for you
and better for all of us if we get the
vaccination unless there is
an overwhelming reason health or
conscience or whatever
that precludes you getting it you really
ought to
get it last week i had to blow out of
the water
a lunatic who was not a muslim
but who nonetheless advertently or
inadvertently sought to sow confusion in
the minds of muslims
by raising the implied possibility
that there was pork in the coronavirus
vaccine this is a lie or at the very
least
a falsehood it is false whether he meant
it deliberately
or not there is absolutely
nothing haram nothing forbidden
to muslims in the coronavirus vaccine
so don't let that kind of false
propaganda false information maybe even
disinformation
put you off from getting the vaccine and
i
am the living proof that you can be back
at your work
immediately after getting it
it is ironic though that it was the
british army that gave it me
given the snp if they had their way
there wouldn't be a british army or at
least it wouldn't be
in scotland in fact the british army has
pulled
the scottish nationalist government out
of a very deep hole
after the fiasco of the rollout of their
vaccination feel free to let me know if
i'm wrong
or indeed if you think i'm right
we'll be talking of course if you want
to
about the alex salmond affair
in the immediate aftermath of his
failure to appear at the committee of
inquiry he failed to appear
because the committee of inquiry
had censored his evidence you couldn't
make
up you go into a committee of inquiry
you swear to tell the truth the whole
truth
and nothing but the truth but the
committee won't allow you
to tell the whole truth as a matter of
fact
they go to extraordinary lengths to make
sure you can
hardly tell any of the truth at
all so alex almond did the right thing
in refusing to go the big question is
what does he do next
if you've got a point of view on that
let me know
and i told you there's going to be a
tunnel
it was going to be a bridge but it was a
bridge too far
boris likes bridges uh but it seems he's
up for a tunnel this tunnel from stran
ra
in my own area south of scotland
will tunnel under the irish sea
and emerge in the northeast irish port
of lorne a wonderful wonderful
idea it'll cost 10 billion pounds
which is a mere bag of tell compared to
eat out to help out
remember that but the 10 billion pounds
will not be
expenditure unlike the eat out
eta to eat out to eat out to
whatever it was the slogan was
it will in this case actually pay
back dividends for the rest of time
eat out to help out was spaffed against
a wall
within an hour or two of having been
consumed
10 billion for a tunnel that will link
forever
the mainland of britain and northern
ireland
is a very good idea it'll create
lots of work especially as the a75 will
have to become
a motorway especially as the
railway line between dumfries and stran
ra
will have to be souped up reinstated
first
and then souped up it's fantastic
news for scotland it's fantastic news
for scotland in britain and it's
fantastic
news for the people of northern ireland
indeed for the people of
all ireland it's a win-win
win and everybody should get behind it
just because boris johnson came up with
it
as a matter of fact i proposed it long
before he was even prime minister but
just because boris johnson's the man
that's doing it
doesn't make it a bad idea
so stop being churlish
nicola sturgeon and embrace it by the
way
it'll be a strategic british asset
it will be nothing to do with hollywood
no one in the right mind would delegate
to hollywood
a project of that strategic importance
and size
after all they can't even build a couple
of
ferries on the clyde which once built
the queen elizabeth so we'll be
talking about all of these things we'll
be talking
about the coronavirus of course with
moat's own
medic dr ranjit bra physician
surgeon all matinee idol
superstar that's taken us through all of
this pandemic and will be with us
right up until the end and indeed beyond
the end because
well there are other health issues that
we'd love to
talk about when we get the chance now
we've got a poll
running at least i hope it's running
will trump begin preparations for a 2024
presidential run a yes b
no c will he send ivanka instead
you can vote on my twitter feed
which is at george galloway blue tick
don't be confused by imitators now
it's valentine's day so i've got to
showcase
the work of my own wife this is
gayatri's latest how so then
and it's on china well it is the chinese
new year kung hi fat choi
remember 9 11 remember the terrorists
killing innocent people in the united
states
britain france germany remember these
countries then fighting these terrorist
organizations isis
al-qaeda the war on terror there's one
country
in particular at war with these same
terrorist organizations
a country that has more muslims than the
entire population
of the eu a country where one province
has
more mosques than the entirety of the
united states
that country is china yes china the ones
you see
them attacking in the news over
coronavirus hong kong
tibet taiwan
lately china has been defamed over its
muslim
uyghurs you see does this group the east
turkmenistan islamic movement for
decades
the united states has designated if a
terrorist
organization because they've been found
fighting everywhere
from afghanistan to syria to libya
the east turkmenistan islamic movement
is china's
al-qaeda and all means of
de-radicalization
is being used to defeat them this east
turkmenistan islamic movement
though still involved in terrorism has
now been
removed by the us from the designated
terrorist
organization list and others like
twitter
and even the british foreign office have
taken up the etim cause
war is peace and peace is war yes
the authors of the wmd hopes are active
again
but why weren't we all supposed to be
fighting
against al qaeda and isis is it to do
with weakening china
is it to stop its economic rise is
spreading fake news about china
huawei and its muslims and the rest the
way
to stop china's growing power you decide
muslims from palestine to kashmir to
iran will surely wonder about that
but china will solve its extremism
problem
and china will not allow any foreign
country to interfere in
her domestic affairs any longer
president biden
take note
[Music]
quite funky that actually well done well
done young reuben a star is
born do follow them will you how so then
on twitter how so then thank you very
much
indeed uh for that now my paul is doing
amazing business almost a thousand votes
in
less than 20 minutes will trump begin
preparations
for a 2024 presidential run yes
71 percent no 19
c ivanka instead
actually rather weak 10 974 people
have voted let's see if our first
guest of the evening has a view
on all of that he is of course literally
the one
and the only dr chris hedges chris
welcome back to the mother of all talk
shows
uh very nice to see you again when i do
see you he's vanished chris can you hear
me
yeah chris yes you're welcome i gave you
this big fulsome buildup and you missed
it all
but never mind never mind you can get on
you can get on catch up okay listen
donald trump's acquittal only man ever
to be impeached twice only man ever to
be
acquitted twice wasn't it all just a
terrific waste
of time and money wasn't it all just
displacement
activity by the democrats it was it was
posturing
uh especially by the democratic party
that
uh was responsible in many ways not only
for trump
uh but for the institution
of a series of measures that violate
constitutional law that had were carried
out by trump but had also been carried
out by obama
so yes it was
and and everybody knew the outcome in
advance
um so yeah it was it was kind of a
political theater
yeah it's not that you your government
doesn't have
other things to do uh of course it has
a great many at home and abroad
i was saying in my opening remarks that
the
for those who voted for joe biden on the
promise
that he was going to rejoin the iran
nuclear
deal for example the news that actually
they will only rejoin it
if iran complies with a series
of unacceptable demands from iran's
point of view
meaning that the americans will not be
rejoining
the iran nuclear deal these kind of
things
are bound to become a disappointment
to different sections of the electorate
the fourteen 1400 instead of
the 2000 uh the failure to
uh to do these things will eventually
cost the democrats yeah i mean the
the difference between the trump
administration and the bible
administration is largely rhetorical
uh i mean on the middle east nobody's
talking about moving the embassy back
to tel aviv from jerusalem by the way uh
which was supported by chuck schumer
uh so uh the the yes the and
and the and the deep uh uh
disconnection and anger of all of it
legitimate by
uh at a dispossessed working class is
not
going to be addressed in fact the only
way it's addressed is by shutting it
down
through cancel culture by and i was
against removing
trump from social media for this reason
uh so
they will demonize them they already are
demonizing them
this is what the media platforms which
serve the democratic party establishment
are doing they are being censored
through
social media silicon valley media
outlets
and uh so we're gonna we're gonna try to
erase them we're gonna make them go away
we're not gonna deal with a root
problem that uh would drive people to
storm the capital
in anger uh and what is the result the
result will be that it will
exacerbate both the anger and probably
the
extremist violence because it becomes
the only way i'm not
condoning it of course in any way but it
becomes the only way
left by which these people can express
themselves in a closed political system
it's very dangerous isn't it because we
both know and
you don't need to look in the crystal
ball you can read the book
uh by suppressing rolling a rock
over something doesn't make it go away
just under that rock it becomes even
more toxic
this is your thesis isn't it that
whether trump runs again or not
is immaterial if he runs again you'll be
a more toxic
trump and if he doesn't run again
somebody more dangerous than donald
trump
will emerge in his stead
yeah exactly i mean uh the perhaps the
you know
the the kind of dark blessing of trump
is that he was so inept
uh he had no real organizational
abilities he had no
uh real political ideology he couldn't
pay attention he had
sort of the attention span of a
four-year-old uh
but yes trump responded to a phenomena
i remember uh speaking with the great
scholar of fascism fritz stern
once who grew up in nazi germany left as
a refugee
uh he taught at columbia university and
he said in germany there was a yearning
for fascism before the word
fascism was invented and that's what you
get here
so trump is a symptom trump is a product
trump is not the disease and with or
without trump if you don't
deal with the serious uh anatomy and
dislocation
and disenfranchisement and uh you know
rupture of social bonds
uh that have afflicted the white working
class and in fact you
demonize them calling them deplorables
the way hillary clinton has done or
using
cancel culture to block their speech and
shut them
out of social media you're exactly right
what you're doing is dumping fuel
on a fire yes
does anyone other than people of your
caliber ever talk about that is there
anyone
for example in the democratic party
uh that understands
that trump is the product he's not the
disease
well not in the democratic party
establishment because of course they're
all corporate mandarins
we only have one party in the united
states it's the corporate party
uh and you can vote for its friendly
fascism
face where it talks about diversity or
species of corporate colonialism where
women and people of color and
people with different sexual
orientations run the empire or you can
again it's kind of more vulgar crude
racist
face uh embodied in a figure like trump
but the system marches forward and i
think as you
uh mentioned in terms of uh the biden
administration
very very little other than a rhetorical
and perhaps a certain amount of civility
or decorum that's brought back
very little and tends to change and
that's very dangerous
now uh will he now begin
you gave us response to his acquittal
uh that the maga make america great
again
project was just beginning uh
and that much lay ahead what do you
think he means by that chris
well i i think he would like to
resuscitate his political career
i don't know if that's going to be
possible
i mean i found the removal of trump's
from his social media
quite frightening not because of course
i approve
of much of what trump tweeted but
because it shows the
uh the power the wholesale power of
censorship by these
monoliths out of silicon valley and i
think that as
the situation deteriorates this
censorship will become more pronounced
so they may be able to cut out a figure
like
trump but then they'll get somebody like
tom cotton or mike pompeo both of whom
want to run and are a much more adept
and therefore
much more dangerous uh political entity
the 75 million that voted for trump
are they potentially transferable to
either of those two
individuals or others or does trump have
to find maybe
a more direct surrogate one of his own
family
that's a good question and i don't know
uh uh
is the short answer uh clearly
trump uh and you saw it in the fact that
republican
uh figures in the senate refused to
impeach him although many of them
including mitch mcconnell loathed trump
uh because they fear him uh how
effectively he can mobilize his base to
resurrect his own career
promote one of his own or do we see the
rise of another
uh demagogue in the figure of pompeo or
someone else
that that's an unknown but that the the
kindling is there
for that kind of uh uh political
extremism is is without doubt what does
joe biden have in mind
for the tens of millions of unemployed
americans
uh the people still facing uh
eviction uh the people that he seems to
imagine
fourteen hundred dollars when they get
it will somehow
allow them to cancel their debt as if
people
have only incurred 1400 worth of debt
in an entire year what does biden have
to say to these people what is he going
to do
for these people well he doesn't work
for those people and he hasn't
throughout his entire political career
he used to be called senator credit card
because that's where
a lot of the big credit card companies
are based who also employed his son
hunter he has assiduously served
corporate and imperial power
he was one of the authors of the patriot
act he's talked about a new domestic
terrorism law i think that's what he's
going to say to them
so you're going to take it you're going
to swallow it uh he's going to serve uh
big business and uh and corporate
entities as he always have
and if you don't like it he's going to
use the uh
formidable resources of the state to
crush you
and finally on his foreign policy he did
to be fair uh avoid the potential
cataclysm of the
start treaty running out uh he did talk
with the chinese leader uh xi uh
on the telephone for two hours this week
notwithstanding the
criticism i just made about his iranian
uh dimash is at least some stability
vis-a-vis the super powers
of russia and china likely to be a
hallmark
of joe biden no the democratic party
will ramp up the red baiting uh the use
of russia as a way to shut down
domestic critics uh that that you know
they
they refuse to acknowledge their own
uh culpability and the betrayal of the
working class
uh they blame the 2016 election on
russia
uh and and so uh and russia is an easier
target
they have a much harder time taking on
china because everything in the united
states is made in china and there's this
uh faustian pact between uh amazon and
apple
and walmart and all these other
companies that use
slave labor in china so uh no i i don't
think so
i i think that there will be attempt to
re-knit traditional alliances that trump
ruptured but i actually don't think
there will be
seismic differences in terms of uh
foreign and imperial policy between
trump and biden
finally and i'm grateful for your time
chris uh
are the clintons gone uh or do we now
have
as it were the sons and daughters of the
clintons
running things well the clinton
it's like tony blair uh in britain so
you had
huge segments of the labor party that
retained loyalty to
blair blairites and took down jeremy
corbyn
and you have the same kind of clinton
figures
within the democratic party people
groomed
and subservient to the clinton machine
uh
and they're there and they can do a lot
of damage in the same way that the
blairites
have done a lot of damage and labor
interesting
chris hedgers as always peerless thank
you very much indeed for joining us on
the mother
of all talk shows how's the poll uh
going
will trump begin preparations for a
presidential run
yes 71 no 18 ivanka
instead 11 1
156 people have voted
in half an hour very very interesting
you can vote now
on my twitter feed now this week
i did an rt short on a matter
on which i seek to dilate once
you have seen it here it is my short
for rt on the brave new world of
transmania
listen i need to be quick because my
wife has to go and chest feed
my six-month-old baby she is the
birthing parent of my little baby
this transmania has gone far enough
[Music]
earlier a health board comprised
of physicians and medical professionals
decided that henceforth mothers
were no longer breastfeeding no longer
mother's milk no longer the
everything that was womanhood
had to be cancelled in this cancel
culture
era of ours all
to please a lobby which is
completely out of control and
is bent towards the interests of a
tiny tiny number of people
in britain and the lobby almost
none of them trans people themselves
have made it a crime almost literally
to speak out in fact if you're in
scotland when the hate crime bill
comes into being even around your own
dinner table you'll be arrested
for speaking like this why do i say it's
transmania and its supporters
transmaniacs
not because i'm a prude i'm very far
from that not because i'm homophobic
i have a stonewall award 30 years
old for standing up for gay rights when
there were rather fewer people around in
parliament who are prepared to
do it no i'm against it because it is
cancelling
women it is negating the idea
of woman womanhood with all
of the things that come with it without
which we would have
no human race at all it's
women that give birth it's women that
produce
mother's milk and if they didn't
where would we be the truth is
women's space women's status
the whole idea of women is under threat
in western countries my own included
like never before do you think the
suffragettes
went to jail died on race courses
under charging horses chained themselves
to railings
fought for women's rights so that a
hundred years later
women could be effectively erased
in favor of some amorphous status all
in the interests of liberal mania
i think it's time to call a halt
the scottish justice minister puts me in
jail
for saying this or not i no longer
care men are men and women are
women they each have very carefully
scientifically
and physically designed characteristics
they have roles the most important of
which
is that women give birth
i don't care what the consequences are
i'm not
cowed by the reign of intellectual
terror
that sees even prominent feminists
actually particularly prominent
feminists
hunted down as if they were wizened old
reactionaries
for standing up for the rights of women
this is all gone far enough
it's about time we all stood up and be
counted
say no to the reign of intellectual
terror
say no to the no platforming of those
who stand up for women
it's time to stand up for women and men
better start joining in too
have something to say do you disagree
with george
then call us now and give us your view
if you agree or you disagree phone the
show let me know
but there's breaking news it says here
a spokesperson for the duke and duchess
of sussex who's the who are they what's
their real names
oh prince harry and megan okay that's a
bit more important
a spokesperson for the duke and duchess
of sussex
has just confirmed the couple are
expecting a baby
the spokesperson said we can confirm
that archie is going to use our that's
their son right
the arch is going to be a big brother
the duke and duchess of sussex are
overjoyed
to be expecting their second child
well congratulations uh to uh
your royal highnesses that is an
interesting question chris
are they still royal highnesses and is
there for this baby
a royal baby i'm sure we'll be fixated
for the next nine months
or yeah what do you think is
she he a royal baby
why why do i care
one man with a point of view on that
breaking news and on the foregoing
about chest feeding
i'm not making that up in case any of
you thought that was a spoof
chest feeding according to the sussex
hospital trust
is how we should describe breast feeding
so we can be more inclusive
to blocks who identify as women
and who can't either breastfeed or
chest feed am i going mad jim davidson
britain's great comedian star of stage
screen and television
has been listening to the show and has
phoned in jim
welcome how are you george i'm the
better for hearing your lovely voice
haven't seen you for
ages jim before i ask you what you're
doing
what's your view on this chest feeding
and mothers now being described as
birthing parents as the world as a world
gone mad
i i think it uh an economic
uh landmine really because comedians
don't have to pay for scriptwriters
anymore
george it's ridiculous isn't it the the
world has gone as the pendulum gone
so far back now we all know we've made
mistakes
and and if you look at what's going on
now with with
with uh people can't wait to trip people
up and say
yes well done but should have done it
earlier yes
well done but it shouldn't have happened
in the first place uh and now
and i think the pendleton's gone too far
yeah and and
but jim jim he here's the rob now you
and i
are on the same side as jermaine grier
and the radical feminists standing up
for
women against a lobby that wants to
cancel
women imagine i know imagine that
well first of all if there was no women
the world would be a terrible place
and i'd be a multi-millionaire georgia
as you know
um i've um no i i think the world
is going bonkers who puts the brakes on
here who decides where all this stuff is
going
we need you to say hang on everybody
let's stop this now
and let's take a step back and look at
reality
yeah that's what i decided to do in
making that short
because nobody else will do it because
the political parties
are terrified of the transmaniacs the
by the way almost none of whom are trans
people themselves
in fact a lot of trans people have
communicated to me
in the last 24 hours that they never
asked for any of this
this is people being more royal than
the king more catholic than the than the
pope so i've decided i'm going to say
this far
and no further and then i wake up this
morning gym
and a member of the labor shadow cabinet
is proposing that instead of mr
and mrs we should now all address each
other as
mx
[Laughter]
oh that's well that'll do me that'll be
a bit confusing on father's day
indeed mixomitosis in
labor front bench i mean
i'm not an old foggy i'm not a wizard
reactionary
i'm actually you are an old folky
but there's one thing that everyone
should decide that you should be
on the front bench of the labour party
an
opposition has to have an opposition
that has a counter
argument not someone that says you're
wrong you should have done this before
and whatever
now let's look at sakia stamina who i
think
has an uncanny resemblance to barney
rubble
from the flintstones is that his job to
just say
you should have done it earlier you
should have done this you should have
done that
is it the opposition her majesty's
opposition
has a role it has a role to hold the
government to account
and to say hang on you're wrong but
we'll help you find a way through
is that what you would do george yes and
they'd know they'd been in a game if i
was
on the front bench opposite them who
knows never we know don't know what lies
ahead
uh can you wear a hat in the chamber no
no you can't
former ses men will jump on you if you
even approach
the
you know that talking of comedic
possibilities there was a time
when i was in parliament that if you
wish to raise
a point of order during a vote
you actually had to put on a top hat
and the sergeant-at-arms had one
under his desk for such eventualities
and i i put this top hat on once
beautiful silk it was jim
and i didn't want to take it off it was
absolutely
lovely now tell us quickly what what
you're doing now
now that the theaters are closed um
how can people follow you jim well they
can follow me on my
tv uh station called ustream they can
get that on www
where it's not just me but i've got all
the comedians all
the all the guys that are struggling i
formed a tv
station so that they can all go on there
and and do what they need to do do you
know what george when you say you stream
do you mean y
or u no no no you as in the
letter you yeah uni uniform stream but
stream is
s-t-r-e-m-e
and it's it's great this is this is the
way
if you look at the bbc if you look at
channel 5 and channel 4 you know there's
someone dictating what is going to be
said on that channel
this is what the most wonderful thing is
watching you
and listening to you talking sense we
know
there's no one going to be your boss
george don't you worry about that
god bless you john that's a very lovely
thing to say
and if bobby's uh also on the channel
bobby davro
give him my love will you i miss you
both jim
take care of friend god bless thanks
very much telling it
keep keep doing this george we need you
george we need you
there's a bit where the right wing and
the left wing join i've
always said it and it's called common
sense and you're loaded with it take
care george god bless you jim thanks
very much that was unexpected
jim davidson and uh you stream that's
the letter
u s r s-t-r-e-m-e
uh i'll be uh logging on to that for
sure now relationship goals
i've got them you've got them we've all
got them but joe
barnett is one of the leading dating
coaches
in the uk she helps people navigate
their personal lives
especially when there is a breakthrough
needed
single married or divorced married
joe offers coaching to help people move
forward
she even helps people to write the
perfect online dating profile
she wrote an ebook in 2012 how to get a
date
now she's been interviewed by many other
television channels and newspapers but
she's never been on the world stage
before
and i'm glad to welcome joe barnett joe
welcome uh to the mother of all talk
shows you're following me
you're following jim davidson
unexpectedly
i'm fabulous now listen um
if you were a newlywed or a childless
couple
the last 12 months has been marvelous
you certainly know each other a lot
better
now if you get my drift and there's
probably a baby coming along soon
if you're a couple with children
like me lots of children it's been
pretty hellish
actually trying to keep everything
together on the
romantic front what about
single people entirely who had no
partner
to lock down with this must be the most
barren year
in in human history joe tell us
so that you could you've covered a
spectrum
of relationships there so we jump
straight to singles and of course
that's the area that i specialize in and
i do feel for singles during lockdown
lockdown was definitely
didn't can take them take them into
consideration
you know it's it's been a challenge and
but i do
encourage singles to carry on
with the dating apps meeting people
socializing and within the restrictions
within what you
can do carry on looking to make
connections
because no one wants to be on their own
during lockdown and there are plenty of
people
out there on the apps looking for
relationships so
within social distancing and with
virtual dating
there's a fair amount of kind of
background work that i encourage my
clients to do and it's also a great time
to think about what you really want in a
relationship
and what you've got to bring to the
relationship what do you need to work on
in yourself and people are taking
time to really focus on that as well
uh you you nearly had me for a moment
when you said that
people should be meeting other people
because i was i had this vision of
um making a date that you would walk
past somebody
in the park but not sit down on the
bench with them because
of course that's not allowed but you
mean virtually
is that really actually is that really a
thing joe
do people date virtually yes
people do everything virtually you know
the
the process is still the same because
before you meet
face to face i would always say you need
to have a couple of conversations
and ideally even a facetime to see if
there's a connection
because you're wasting your time meeting
someone that you have
no flow and no communication with so
that process that sifting process
looking for those common values that
share and that click is the way it's
always been
and then once you've had a couple of
interactive face time calls
you can arrange for a social distance
walk if
if both of you feel comfortable and i
know plenty of people who have met
during lockdown
really i thought all these uh dating
companies and all i thought they'd all
be bust because
um people would just be in their own
homes
and dating would be a dim and distant
memory
you know it depends which way you take
it there are people who are going to say
right let's put this on hold you know we
thought it was a few weeks a few months
it's now been a year
and and there are other people who will
be a bit
more um determined to keep things
going and and still look for
a partner in the same way they would
before that apps are busier than ever
you know bumble tinder they are hinged
they've gone through the roof there are
millions of subscribers
to these apps so it's a good time to be
on them
not for me i'd be in big trouble if i
was on them
because i'm happily i'm happily married
but uh
i'm sure the singleton's listening
watching
i will take that on board i don't want
to
because there may be children listening
i don't want to explore too much
uh what this interactivity on the uh
on the uh on the the face timing
uh might be what about people that are
in relationships
how do they keep it together in these
extraordinary circumstances
now there's a question so people who are
in relationships
it's constant work you know people think
that a relationship once you're in a
relationship
you're going to be happy and live
happily ever after
and it's plain sailing and actually
that's where the work begins
because you have to constantly work at a
relationship
you've got to be thinking about two
people now it's not just you
it's another person considering their
needs what's going on for them
and i think the mistake people make is
we're all so caught up
in in what we want and getting our needs
met
and our fulfillment and sometimes you
have to think about what's going on for
your partner
what do they need and making time to do
fun things together
you know doing an activity watching a
movie listening to a podcast
even cooking to put some time aside
where you
turn off all your devices and really
give your partner
your full attention and just have a fun
night in the kitchen cooking something
together
eating something together and making
quality time for your partner that's
what will really nourish a relationship
in these difficult times
sounds good to me now birds do it bees
do it even educated
fleas do it uh is
there really nothing new under the sun
our people still looking for what they
always looked for
and do they by and large even with the
aid of modern technology
still go about it in roughly the same
way joe
you know people have always wanted
connection
people feel validated when they have
someone to love and someone who loves
them
so it really is that simple what i
notice
with clients who come to me is that the
list
is sometimes unrealistic you know and if
your
tick list includes someone who speaks
five languages
and is well traveled and is a size 8 and
has this certain hair color
you're going to find it virtually
impossible to meet someone
so what i do is i hone in on values you
know core values that are really
important and then look at those and
kind of
don't focus on some of the other stuff
make it more
more basic and more personal about the
things that you actually need rather
than the things that you
think you need because we can make it so
complicated
and that's what keeps people single
because you know they think well
i've been single this long i'm not going
to compromise
um and that's great but is the bar so
high
that no one's going to fit that criteria
you know and do you do you tick every
single box because nobody is perfect
and i would like to see people be a bit
more realistic
in what they're looking for and a bit
more giving in what they
have to offer and then i think that we
would meet somewhere in the middle
and have more chance of people having
better longer lasting relationships
joe how do people follow you not that
i'm going to but
for those that do have you got a website
people can consult
i do it's www dot joe barnett
dating coach dot me dot uk fabulous
happy valentine's day to you
thank you very much indeed joe for
joining us let's take a call from
australia uh
michael is in sydney if you get my drift
uh go ahead michael go ahead
yeah hi george uh look look mate i'd
just like to
talk about the topic you're talking
about before about um
transmania yeah and um i think it
transfers across to things like sports
as well
i mean has anyone bothered to stop to
ask women athletes
such as people doing taekwondo at the
olympics or maybe i don't know female
boxing might be getting picked soon
or or things like that how they would
feel competing against
people who had been males all their life
until maybe into their mid 20s and
suddenly trends over into a
you know into a female um and also like
you know children
having the right to depict their gender
at age
six and take hormone replacement therapy
to to stop their natural development at
age because
they can't go to the pub um they can't
even vote they can't even drive
um but we're giving them the right to
choose their gender and take potentially
you know life altering what basically
you know hormones physiologically
altering medications
at their own choice at the tikis of age
and
courts and organizations actually you
know taking children away from parents
there's been cases
and calling it child abuse so they won't
let their parent they wanted their
children at age six choose their gender
i mean i know for example when i was um
about six years of age or i dress up a
little bit of peep for a party my
parents were just going i would take the
dress off for a week
well i'm not transgender you know i got
a girlfriend and i'm very heterosexual
um you know and i just think it's
something that somebody's crazy women
people bother to stop and ask women how
they feel about people
about this situation well a very
powerful call
michael thank you for it uh actually
many women athletes
have already made clear uh their
absolute rejection the
british olympic swimmers at sharon davis
she spoke very strongly about this and
every effort was made i don't know maybe
it was even successful
to shut her down to uh to cancel her
because she was making the point that
girls and young women are
training putting in all the hours to
become
prize-winning athletes in the swimming
pools on the tracks and so on
and all a man has to do is declare uh
to identify as a woman and bang he's in
the race
against them and with his superior
male strength is likely to uh
win it's a complete outrage
uh i think uh michael last word to you
yeah look george i just totally agree
and you know
my daughter um identifies as bisexual
and i
you know whenever she says yeah well i
married a girl whatever you know
she's 11 now i'd say well look sweetie
it's really too young to really know
what you are
and whatever you are i'll support you
and i love you i'm not homophobic i'm
i'm not a you know i support gay rights
i voted yes in the australian referendum
um you know so it's not a matter of
being you know um anti-gay or queer or
transphobic or anything it's just a
matter of basic common sense
well said common sense from sydney
that's
michael in australia thank you very much
by all means if you have a different
point of view
uh call the show uh the number is if you
are in the uk
oh two or seven seven nine eight two two
five
five or if you're in the us 001
757-744-4480
or you can tweet us at george galloway
at rt uk
news uh so whatever your view
on anything you've heard here or
anything you're going to
hear uh on the tonight show please
let me know trump should he begin
is he going to begin preparations yes
71 no 19
ivanka instead no she's only got
10 support you can vote on my twitter
feed but first
it's time for the news with jamie law
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news at least 15 million
people in the uk have had their first
coronavirus jab vaccine minister nazim
sahawi has said
the milestone was reached just over two
months after the first jab was delivered
in britain on december the 8th
it comes after ministers said the uk was
on track to meet its pledge of offering
a vaccine to
everyone in the top four priority groups
by monday
from monday the vaccine rollout is being
expanded to include
over 65s and those deemed clinically
vulnerable
one dose of a covered 19 vaccine gives
protection after three weeks a leading
epidemiologist has said
professor tim spector of king's college
london who runs the zoe covert 19
surveillance app said data collected
from 50 000 users vaccinated with either
the pfizer
or oxford astrazeneca jab showed that
one dose gave 46
protection after two weeks rising to 67
after three to six weeks the app uses
information submitted by
more than four million users across the
world to predict
and track coronavirus infections across
the uk
and other countries new zealand's prime
minister jacinda ardern has ordered the
country's biggest city auckland
to go into lockdown after the discovery
of three
new local coronavirus cases the measure
will last
three days and require residents to stay
at home
ardern said the country was going hard
and early
after the cases were identified new
zealand has won
widespread praise for its handling of
the pandemic
going months without community
transmission the country with a
population of 5 million has recorded
just over 2
300 cases of covet and just 25
deaths the measure in auckland require
its 1.7 million residents to stay at
home
except for essential shopping and work
schools and non-essential shops will
close and entry in and
out of the city is restricted
a woman who made sexual assault
allegations against scotland's former
first minister alex salmond has claimed
that the hollyrood inquiry into the saga
has been more traumatic for her in many
ways than the trial was the woman was
one of nine who gave evidence against
the former first minister of the high
court last year
simon was cleared of all 13 of the
sexual assault charges against him a
committee is now investigating the
scottish government's handling
of the original complaints against mr
salmond the inquiry was intended to
ensure that similar mistakes were not
made
in the future and that women could feel
confident in coming forward with
complaints about alleged
sexual misconduct but the woman told the
bbc that she believed it
descended into a political fight that
made it less likely that other women
would report any concerns
she said the row had effectively allowed
the government to get away with not
being properly scrutinized on its
procedures
a 22 year old indian climate activist
has been arrested after sharing a
document intended to help farmers
protest against new agricultural laws
disharavi is accused of sedition and
criminal conspiracy the documents she
shared a toolkit
which suggests ways of helping the
farmers was first posted by the
prominent
campaigner greta thundberg ravi a
student and one of the founders of the
indian branch of the friday's for future
climate strike
was arrested by delhi police the
protests now in their third month
mark the biggest challenge india's prime
minister narendra modi has faced
new laws loosened rules around the sale
pricing and storage of farm produce
which have protected india's farmers
from the free market for decades farmers
fear that the new laws will threaten
decades-old concessions
such as assured prices and weaken their
bargaining power leaving them vulnerable
to exploitation by private companies
the modi government has offered to
suspend the laws but the farmers want
them replaced
altogether u.s president joe biden has
said his predecessor donald trump's
acquittal for inciting mob violence is a
reminder that democracy is fragile
seven republicans joined the democrats
and voting to convict falling
short of the two-thirds majority needed
to do so
biden said the charge relating to
trump's role in the capital riot last
month was not
in dispute while seeking to move on from
the process
trump has welcomed his acquittal calling
his impeachment a witch hunt
in the senate on saturday the trial
ended with a 57-40
vote in favour of conviction united arab
emirates hope
mission has returned its first picture
of mars the spacecraft entered into an
orbit around the red planet on tuesday
making the uae the first arab nation in
history to have a scientific presence at
earth's
near neighbour the first image will be
followed by many similar views of mars
hope was put into a wide orbit so it
could study the planet's weather and
climate systems which mean that it will
also see the planet's
full disk and finally if it
happens it will show as boxes
after boris johnson the uk prime
minister proposed a link between
scotland
and northern ireland his idea was for a
bridge
but now it seems a 25-mile undersea
tunnel is the way forward according to
the secretary of state for scotland
alastair jack reiterated his support for
the link ahead of the expected release
of a study that could kick off a formal
consultation on the idea
he said that he had talked to the prime
minister and that a tunnel appeared to
be the most viable way forward
johnson first backed the idea of
connecting milan in northern ireland to
strana
and scotland when he was foreign
secretary in 2018
but this appears to have fallen out of
favor as too complex and expensive
with a tunnel now seen as the preferred
options
it would be about 25 miles long not far
off the channel tunnel 31 miles and
provide a road and rail link
a report on uk transport infrastructure
by the head of network rail sir peter
hendy is reportedly imminent and
expected to say that the project
is possible that could kick off a formal
government
feasibility study and that's the latest
here on sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
welcome indeed and be sure and vote on
my poll about donald trump's
uh intentions in the 2024
presidential election you can vote on my
twitter feed at george galloway
lots of comments on the us election and
so on
alberto says it's difficult to believe
that once grey and free people
can be so easily deceived by the
mediocrity and the lies
of the two oligarchic parties
and there isn't even any visible
opposition
to these liars and charlatans
unbelievable
and patricia said president biden was
doing the best he could give the guy a
break
and consider what he was up against and
robert
says biden's a joke he should be in an
old people's home
and joseph said the republican party
cannot stand
trump well the republican leadership
sure
doug says it was a farce trump is a
criminal but
the impeachment was a charade and lex
says i
don't think trump really wanted to be
president
and never thought he'd actually be
elected the presidential runs
were all supposed to be simple airtime
for his ego and businesses well
he didn't account for how bad a
candidate hillary clinton
would turn out to be and andy says of
course trump will run again
his ego is bigger than jeff bezos's
wallet no
no nothing in the world is bigger than
that
he's got to feed it somehow the scary
thing is though i can't see
biden holding him off and siobhan
says no because of his age however he
may be preparing
his offspring for president and john
said i think he will run
for 2024 whether he should is another
question
the people are looking for a change from
the establishment and he
offered that and andy says the system
is too rigged to let him win again and
the media will give him the worst
possible coverage
or cancel him bet you he will have huge
influence though
and send the democrats wild and keith
says i hope he does
i don't agree with some of the things he
did syria
israel but he fought a hard fight with
every msm outlet against him
imagine how bad the planet would be if
hillary had won
and biden is going back on nearly every
promise
he made for his 100 days harry makes the
good point
i think the bull point that donald trump
will be
78 years old in four years time
i'm not sure he'd want the grief again
although
his ego may force him to run and danny
says ego will push him now
and as much as i wanted him to beat
biden i think he's the wrong
candidate for the next election to take
on kamala harris
for the second term and how he says 320
million people in the u.s
if trump biden clinton-style leaders is
the best
they have to offer their citizens all
the rest of the world
what does it really say about humanity
leaders of the free world i wouldn't let
them lead a song
and cyrus says maybe he'll run for
republican
office but not for president that's
intriguing
cyrus and uh in response to my
short my rt short alison says if someone
who was previously referred to as a man
says that they would now prefer to be
referred to as a woman that's absolutely
fine
we just changed the way we talk about
that particular individual
what we don't do is insist that from now
on
all men must be referred to as women
because that would be
insane so if a person who was previously
referred to
as a mother says that they would prefer
to be referred to
as a birthing parent
is there anybody that would be
absolutely fine we just changed the way
we talk about that individual but why on
earth would anyone
insist that all mothers must now be
referred to
as birthing parents it's insanity
and ann says as difficult as it is for
me to say this george i agree with every
single word
time to get out and tell it how it is
why thank you anne and sama says
women are not birthing and feeding
machines for your children
trans women are a minority as you point
out
in the beginning and as minorities we
should support
and protect them trans women are women
and that is something neither you or me
or any law
can change please remember not all women
can have children or breastfeed are
these women
not women too sama why don't you call me
uh oh two o seven seven nine eight two
two five
five if you're in the u.s zero zero one
seven
five seven seven four four four four
eight zero but just for your information
the last thing
in the whole world i regard women as is
either birthing or feeding machines for
my children i take very
very great exception to that
and ford says i totally agree george it
used to be a professional courtesy
to ask clients how they wish to be
addressed
not a problem complying but this
insatiable desire
to mold society to the calling of a tiny
number
is just not on first world problems
let's hear some
problems from the rest of the world
which may have greater connection to
reality vijay prashad is an
historian and journalist and the head of
the tri-continental
institute as such he's constantly on the
move and we catch up with him now
in latin america about which i want to
talk to him vijay welcome you're our
global
roving correspondent without pay
but all the tea you can drink uh thank
you very much indeed for joining us
can we talk about ecuador first of all
for those
who can't place ecuador
it was the ecuadorian embassy that
julian assange
was given asylum in by the previous
president
president rafael correa who won
the affection and admiration of
many people around the world for giving
safe haven
to julian assange when his presidential
term
ended he was succeeded by a man who
at least pretended to be his
uh fan his supporter was going to govern
in the same way
believe or not his name was lenin moreno
but he was no sooner in
office and he was literally selling
julian assange to the americans to the
imf his popularity then became
so low he didn't even run in the recent
presidential election
which took place last week uh please
vijay tell us
what happened in the ecuador election
well it's great to be with you again
george the election
was as expected a spectacle
the candidate who represents the
citizens revolution
andres arouse won the largest number of
votes
but was not able to go above the
threshold
which would have prevented a second
round
he won roughly 36 percent of the vote he
needed to get
40 as a consequence he's going to go in
a few months into a second round
the entire opposition has come together
the organization of american states
which as you know is headquartered in
washington dc
and played its own shenanigans in
bolivia
in november 2019 has basically
thrown its its gloves in the ring
alongside the opposition the united
states government seems to have
tilted the opposition uh put its finger
on the scale
everybody with power seems to be with
this
opposition if you just count up the
number of votes they'd get 70 percent
and raise arouse is going around the
country trying his best
to lift his numbers above the 50 mark
it's going to be really difficult george
it's really tough when you're up against
the oligarchy in ecuador international
institutions
the united states government and the oas
it's hard to go against all of them
when they're standing against you and
could he have done anything
differently could the people who support
him
uh have done anything differently to get
above that crucial 40 percent do you
think
well it's hard to say in the period
right before the election there was
there was just a set of dirty tricks
things that you know we've seen over the
years um
being done when you know for instance
our old friends the cia get involved and
people
like them for instance there was a news
story that broke before the elections
which suggested
that andres arouse who's an economist
trained at
the very best university in mexico spent
two years in the government of raphael
korea
is a man with no blemish nobody has
any corruption allegation against andres
aroused
forget corruption allegation there's no
nothing negative said about him
but a few days before the election a
story was
released to some choice newspapers
alleging
that mr arouse's campaign was financed
by
the farc organization in colombia these
are the former
marxist gorillas who are now above
ground and have a political
organization in colombia it's very clear
that the this was a total fabrication
in fact the video that was released um
you know was said to show
said to be set in colombia turned out
that the birds were
wrong the birds that were in the
background chirping in the video
are not to be found there so
this was a dirty tricks attempt to smear
his campaign
this i think had a mark this had an
impact on
on the voting share that he got but also
um one of the opposition candidates
jackie perez
comes across as a leader of the
indigenous bloc
inside ecuador when in very plain fact
he is essentially a stooge of of the us
state department
he came out even calling for the
organization of american states to get
involved
you know nobody in their right mind
who's a democratically minded person
asked for the organization of american
states to get involved
so these matters this dirty tricks
campaign
the muddiness of having an indigenous
leader stand against you
this did have an impact on the election
election result in the first round and
will this indigenous
leader likely be the victor
well again let's see but by all
indications there seems to be
a lot of pressure to push the opposition
in back into office i mean the entire
state bureaucracy
is essentially on the side of the
opposition
this is an election that should help
people
understand how democracy or democratic
institutions today
have been so badly skewed the democratic
spirit has been sucked out of them
money has really destroyed things but
also the way in which state institutions
are utilized to advantage people in
power
it's a good example of how democracy
is essentially you know become quite the
opposite of what democracy should be
very interesting now uh switching
continents
uh i know that you're uh you're a man
who follows
uh china closely we
uh we aired a video uh which i've no
doubt will be
uh controversial earlier in the show
vijay
in which uh a the people who made the
video
sought to debunk what they believe
i personally also believe is
a deliberate campaign of falsification
of china's relations with its
muslim population which is a huge muslim
population
bigger than the entire population of the
european union and if
china had a muslim problem with that
number of muslims
we'd know much more about it
do you share the view that china is
being unfairly
targeted on the muslim question
well i'll come to that in a minute but
the first thing george is that
who's lecturing china about islamophobia
it's the u.s
state department it's the europeans and
others
i mean look at these countries record
when it comes to
wars in the predominantly muslim lands i
mean
mike pompeo lecturing china about
islamophobia
should make somebody just you know laugh
because
after all he was once the head of the
cia um
what was what is the u.s war in
afghanistan but a crime
against the people of afghanistan there
is that actually illegal war against
iraq that the united states prosecuted
i mean then there's the war in libya you
know where the united states
cavalierly destroyed a country so to
have the united states
stand up and say we are on on the side
of muslims strikes me as
you know it beggars the imagination
frankly so one thing is
well the messenger should be questioned
in the united states in the middle of
its
trade war with china it seems convenient
that it picks up on the question of the
uyghurs
just as it's convenient that the united
kingdom talks about democracy in hong
kong
i mean seriously hong kong was your
colony until yesterday
and now you're interested in democracy
why didn't the united kingdom give hong
kong democracy
the day after they were able to get hong
kong
you know in the aftermath of the opium
war so these people talking about
democracy
and islamophobia strikes me as something
that should raise the hackles of a
normal person
but if we come directly to what's
happening in xinjiang
there's a lot of evidence already in the
public domain about this
look it's a it's a it's a reality that
china has
since the 1950s struggled to integrate
minorities you know
after all there was the minorities
commission which at the time had the
dalai lama as its chairperson
this is something that china has
struggled with china is also
i think in an amazing way been able to
abolish
poverty 850 million people brought out
of poverty lifted themselves out of
poverty
this includes the people in xinjiang
lived in wretched poverty for
generations you know these are things
that the chinese government is doing
they also faced a very serious threat of
you know radicalism coming across the
border from central asia
you know the groups that came from um
you know uzbekistan
kyrgyzstan and so on the seriousness
gravity of that issue had to be met now
instead of going and just sort of
jailing everybody and killing everybody
the chinese developed a procedure of
educating people trying to integrate
them
now you one can call that a re-education
camp or whatever it is
but it's certainly not guantanamo and by
the way
guantanamo which the united states runs
on the occupied part of the island of
cuba is still open for business there
are still
people in guantanamo who are in prison
whereas what one sees
in urumqi and other parts of xinjiang
are people who
had very radical some of them quite
dangerous beliefs who have been brought
in and they're going through a process
i mean you've got to understand what
they are doing
not just throw labels at you know a
process that's very complicated
i don't presume to have an easy answer
to what a government must do when
confronted by this kind of radicalism or
extremism
what a government must do is it must
understand
the process that it's going through and
others need to try to figure out well
you know
what are they doing and do you have any
better suggestions
look the united states better suggestion
is permanent incarceration
is that what they want yeah our drones
vijay prashad thank you as always for
joining us
on the mother of all talk shows go
safely
in latin america now there's been
some kind of dramatic development on the
poll
breaking news on the poll a significant
swing in the last few minutes a massive
change
ivanka is slowly catching up
will trump begin preparations for a 2024
presidential run a yes
48 down 23
no 13 down
6 c ivanka
instead 39
a rise of 29 percent
who put out the message
that it's ivanka that is the one
that is absolutely fascinating now chris
is that on twitter only or on twitter
are we not on telegram tonight
give me these uh to see if there is this
dichotomy that we
discovered last week give me a 60 second
break why don't you
[Applause]
[Music]
well um how did i do i'm sorry prime
minister
at no point did you drive on the
left-hand side of the road
and instead of driving us forward you
made several u-turns
we haven't gone anywhere i think you'll
find
if you turn backwards uh enough times
eventually
you'll go forward so uh did i pass
no you failed miserably but my teachers
said i'd get much higher grades
better look next time this doesn't
happen to people
like me you leave me
no choice
i'm sorry but rules are rules even for
prime ministers
what's on earth is that my mutant
pets dominate cummins
no big algorithm
get it
global higher education with one of the
world's best known iconoclasts
the mother of all talk shows with george
galloway
what we have identified um with a bit of
detective work is that whoever
is behind the big lobby for ivanka trump
is not on telegram which means they're
not russians
because she's only got 14 support
on telegram but she's got 39
support on twitter the plot
thickens you can still vote right up to
nine o'clock
will it be ivanka instead will it be
donald
or will it be neither now
this is the spot where i look back at
the seven days
in our checkered history this is the
week and it's another momentous one
in 1929 it wasn't all chocolates
and roses on valentine's day
in chicago it was bullets and wreaths
when
seven gangsters were killed in what
became known
as the saint valentine's day massacre
killed allegedly on uh why we sing
allegedly
he can't sue us and it definitely was
him
but it says here killed allegedly on al
capone's
orders now it wasn't a wise move
in 1971 by richard nixon
that's not richard nixon that's al
capone but that's richard nixon
when he installed a secret taping system
in the white house
it of course proved his downfall with
the watergate cover-up
when the tapes were replayed and his
guilt was confirmed
it is interesting i was just talking to
a good friend of mine a former captain
of
the scotland rugby team uh earlier today
finley calder richard nixon
was miles ahead he was coasting
against a very very weak democratic
party candidate
george mcgovern he had absolutely no
need to do any
of that stuff let alone talk on tape
about what he had done now on this
uh in this week british and u.s bombers
pounded the ancient german city of
dresden
with high explosives and incendiaries on
this valentine's day actually
in 1945 the city's population was
swollen with refugees
and the death toll from the massive
bombing which leveled the city
was somewhere between 25
000 the uh british claim
and 100 000 the nazi
claim and it was on this day in 1989
when
iranian muslim leader ayatollah khomeini
issued a fatwa against a death threat
sorry a fatwa and a death threat against
british author
salman rushdie and his publishers over
the book
satanic verses not because it was dull
and boring which is
but because it was allegedly blasphemous
there we go what's with all that have we
got a lawyer
through their allegedly blasphemous
the former lebanese prime minister rafiq
hariri
was killed in an assassination in west
beirut in 2005 outside
the saint george hotel which i know well
when the car he was traveling in was
blown up
the british government launched the new
decimal currency
in 1971 alas i'm so old i remember it
when everything that was
a 10 old pence became 10 new pens thus
more than doubling in price now here's
another i remember
only too well on february 15th
in 2003 an estimated 6
to 11 million people around the world
took to the streets to protest
against the war with iraq there were
around 2 million of us marching in
london
alone and i was one of their leaders
uh together with the other leaders of
the stop the war
coalition we had built up
to what was and i think always will be
the biggest ever demonstration in the
history of this
country two million people
demanding no war on iraq it was bitterly
cold
if you were there in hyde park you'll
know what i mean it couldn't actually
have been
colder uh in britain than it was that
day
but there were still millions of people
on the march
and by the time i came to speak i think
i may have been second last they usually
kept me to
the end to keep the crowd there but
actually the cold was such that
they brought me forward and put me on
uh there was still a very well over 1
million people standing in front of me
when i spoke in hyde park on that day
in 2003 now this was the week in 1959
that cuba's revolutionary leader fidel
castro
became the country's youngest of our
premier at the age of
32 he was sworn in as prime minister
in the cabinet room of the presidential
palace
in havana i am one of his
uh biographers though of course and uh
since i raised it here
there's been quite a rush on my fidel
castro
handbook that you can get in my
shop online i'll get you the
address because i always forget it but
since i promoted it on here
we've actually had to send a truck all
the way to
high wickham where our remaining stocks
of the book
were stored in a container and
now we've got them in our shop so if you
want
the fidel castro handbook dedicated
and signed personally by me then you can
do that through my shop there it is
there www
dot george galloway dot shop
now uh in 1963 again i'm old enough to
remember this too
the beatles hit number one in the uk
with please
please me i bought it the british
parliament voted to join what was then
the european common market
in 1972 and we joined on the first
of january in 1973.
it's been all downhill for the common
market
since that day now the serial killer
jeffrey dahmer
was sentenced to life in prison by a
court in wisconsin in 1992
for murdering and dismembering 15
young men and boys dahmer was unable to
convince the jury
that his cannibalism and necrophilia
were the result of madness in 1984
he was murdered by a fellow inmate who
bludgeoned him to death
with a metal bar senator joe mccarthy
the u.s
witch hunter of communists attempted to
subpoena
two generals two american army generals
in 1954 but the secretary of the u.s
army
ordered the two generals to ignore the
summons
now hundreds of people clamored to see
the marriage of pop stars lulu and the
late maurice gibb
of the bee gees in a buckinghamshire
church
in 1969 in this week that one didn't
last
now allegedly our editor ron mccain knew
lulu in her earlier
incarnation uh in glasgow on the streets
of denison but
that may be an old wives tale and on the
19th of february
in 1997 china's paramount leader
dong chao ping died at the age of 92
after suffering
from failing health for several years
ground control to john glenn the first
american to orbit the earth
landed safely in the atlantic ocean in
this week in 1962.
he went into politics and was a democrat
senator for
ohio his home state for 24 years
his interest in space medicine then led
him to persuade nasa
to send him back into space at the age
of 77
in november 1998. he completed the
nine-day
mission on the space shuttle with
another six astronauts
to become the oldest man in space until
i get there and in 1986 in another space
venture
the soviet union opened a new phase in
space exploration
with the launch of the world's biggest
space station mir
which means in english peace and it
lasted for 15 years
up there three years before in 1983
hundreds of people died in the indian
state of assam
as fierce fighting raged in the run-up
to the indian election
this followed the assassination of the
prime minister
indira gandhi villages were set on fire
and bridges and offices burned according
to unofficial figures nearly
3 000 muslims died in the riots
massacred by the ethnic assamese and la
lungs wanted to evict them as part of
protests against so-called
foreigners that's it seven days that
shaped our present
that certainly was the week that
was let's take a call from kenny in
london
go ahead kenny hi george here i just
want to talk about the trends issue that
you were speaking about earlier
in front of me by uh douglas murray
it's called the madness of codes and
he's got a chapter
called trans and he talks about it and
he's got a paragraph here
just like that you do if that's okay oh
yeah go ahead
okay i was standing
on the corner all right
i'll get him off get him off he's a
nutter
kenny in london is a nutter let's see if
joshua in manchester is any better
hi joshua can you hear me yeah can you
follow that one you're not going to sing
to me are you
unfortunately not i was a good thing um
i'm a big fan of your george and i'm a
member of the um your
party the workers party okay um there's
just one thing that i
disagree with you on and i wanted to
discuss with you and that was the
muslims in china oh yeah go ahead um so
you've said that in the past that um
the government from america and the
government of britain they don't care
about the muslims in iraq or
anywhere else in the world that's
incontestable i think
yeah i completely agree on that um and i
whilst i agree with that does that make
the claims about
china inherently untrue could it not
just be like a convenient stick to beat
china with but still be true
uh it could of course in theory uh but
as
uh vijay prashad pointed out earlier
uh given that it's coming from the
people that told us iraq had
weapons of mass destruction was
bristling with
chemical nuclear biological weapons
which turned out to be a gigantic lie
uh given that these claims are coming
from the same
lying machine i think they ought to be
taken with a substantial pinch of salt
uh i think vijay was extremely honest in
how he
dealt with the question he said that
china has struggled with
radicalized extremized fanatic
muslims supporters of al-qaeda and isis
now you've got two choices of how you
deal with these people you either
kill them as the united states
would undoubtedly do if they emerged in
alabama
or you try and de-radicalize them
and china's trying to de-radicalize them
last word to you joshua so yeah i
i agree that i wouldn't necessarily take
the government's
uh word or the media's word on that well
i mean there are charities like
amnesty international saying that there
are a million people being held against
their will
are they are they lying i mean what what
evidence have you seen that they're not
surprised that a member of the workers
party of britain is praying in aid
amnesty international
uh um that's a new one on me
but the uh reality is uh we don't know
how many people are being de-radicalized
i believe it's far far far fewer
than a million but it will be some
thousands
because this uh east turkmenistan
islamic fighting organization
has got thousands of people fighting in
syria
it's got thousands of people fighting in
libya
it's got actually thousands of people
fighting in nagorno-karabakh
most recently uh as mercenaries
for the for the azeri
uh forces there so if there's thousands
of them fighting overseas
i would think there's probably quite a
few thousand
uh chinese al-qaeda types in china
wouldn't you i mean well
that's possible if there were millions i
would say that sounds more like a
collective punishment type thing rather
than
just targeting uh you know people tell
us that's not how i see it
it's not how uh i think vijay prashad
who
is not a member of the workers party uh
saw it uh earlier you've got the
responsibility
as the man making these uh inferences
to give me some evidence for that don't
you joshua
yeah i i agree that it's on it's some
people that claim
things to prove it rather than you to
disprove it
yeah but i mean i don't i don't know
where to gather evidence either way if
we can't trust the
media which i mean i agree they tell a
lot of lies and we can't government
where should we be looking well i i i
trust the
uh information from china
and china has been honest about it
that it has a problem with fanatic
muslims so do we now we put them in
prison forever
and rightly so in america they would be
killed they would be killed extra
judicially actually
in america in china they are not being
uh
but how what is the best way to deal
with the fanatic
islamist extremists is of course uh
up to every country themselves to decide
joshua thanks for that call um let's
hear from
eric in dublin on the tunnel go ahead
eric
good evening george good evening to you
sir
yeah i'm a big fan of your show um i
really appreciate
you what you say and what you watch what
you talk about uh you have an awful
platform there for everybody so really
appreciate it
and thank you very much for inviting me
on and george i just got back to the
tunnel yeah it's for me
uh as i'm a proud irishman uh from the
republic of ireland um i'm all open for
um you know a wider ireland and
expanding into europe and
the uk which is our closest partner
but i have a a i think we need to have
think this a bit more when it comes to
opening up a border between the uk
and ireland via a tunnel we need to
especially when it comes to immigration
uh you look at calais and uh uh
well the right colleague they did the
british tunnel there between the
the uk and france and uh issued that
house with immigration people coming in
i just think this could be another
funnel for um illegal immigration coming
into ireland which will have a massive
problem now
via belfast here was me naively thinking
you meant the other way
uh no well naively you may you
might be but you're here see eric here's
my point
uh there is free movement of uh
east european central european
cheap labor into the republic of ireland
because because you're in the eu
but no such right no such right now
exists
in britain so if there was going to be
any illegal immigration it would almost
certainly be
the other way around eric it would be
eastern european people that
were now allowed to come to britain but
are allowed to go to
ireland who might try and get through
the tunnel but
it won't be that kind of tunnel eric
it'll be
like the uh like the channel tunnel
you'll drive your car
onto a railway and the railway will take
you
uh there
yes i know george uh it all starts out
in a very positive manner but eventually
there's many loopholes which are
exploited by
of last year no you haven't you've done
well thanks eric
in dublin simon is in london on the
china question
go ahead simon hi george the only
the thing i want to bring up with with
regards to what just just said
um uh with regards to the yugos you you
never seem to
uh you never seem to understand uh
basically what you what you seem to do
is you always seem to give
china all the credit with regards to
this and the treatment it's very clear
from the media from everything that i've
seen
that chinese are treating you muslims
terribly and you know you won't say
anything against
anything just chinese purely because
they share your ideology the socialist
ideology
well let me stop you there for a moment
um
why do you think a media that cares
nothing nothing for the plight of
muslims in
kashmir in iraq
in palestine in iran in libya
in afghanistan actually suddenly cares
about the plight of muslims in china why
do you think that is simon
i'm not talking about those countries
i'm not i'm not saying the western
countries you say i'm not saying the
western media is not hold on
i'm not saying western media is not
biased western media is terrible as i
said
you've seen it you've seen yourself with
the bbc what i'm saying is you never
criticize the chinese
purely because they themselves share a
socialist agenda like yourself
well let me come back to that point
because china's actually a booming
capitalist economy as well as
aspects of socialism and i'm not
involved in
any of that i'm telling you what i think
just like i told you
uh on this day in 2003
what i thought about the same britain
and america now
defending muslims in china about to
launch a devastating war
against the muslims in iraq so i tell
the truth as i see it son now
i'm asking you it's the second time i've
asked you
why would i believe people who don't
give tuppence
for muslims anywhere else in the world
when they tell me something about
muslims in china why would i believe
that
simon i listen i don't i don't believe
in the
british media either as i said there's
plenty of other sources within the uh
upon
the british in the western media china
muslims tell me tell me then tell me
them simon
tell me them where are your other
sources you've seen the concentration
camps
you are now relying on the media outlets
yes but not western media outlets
which ones it doesn't matter which ones
i mean it doesn't matter which ones
because i'm asking you you're live on my
show
and i'm asking you what are these media
outlets
that you are praying in aid which ones
again
it's a relevant question the question
here was why is it that you seem to
defend
you defend socialist countries whenever
whenever they're doing whenever they're
committing atrocities and yet whenever
other countries uh carry out the same
atrocities like america and britain
you've made that right you don't you
don't get you you don't seem to care
you've made that point so now deal with
this one
what is the evidence that you
are relying on you are refusing
you have thrice refused to say
which media outlets you are relying on
for this information i give you a fourth
opportunity
you yourself said that the uh chinese
were putting
the uh the the yugo muslims through
camps re-education camps as i said
radicalization comes pretty much you
yourself said that
on this show just a
it is a section of the
uyghur muslims there are many other
muslims in china there are more muslims
in china
than the entire population of the eu
there are more
mosques for uighurs
in one province than there are in the
entire
united states so we're not talking about
the uyghur muslims we're talking about a
section
of them the fanaticized
extramized al-qaeda eyes
section how would you deal with the
al-qaeda elements in the east turkestan
islamic movement or do you support them
simon
uh no again you're kind of planning the
issue here as i said there's no proof
that al qaeda is in china for starters
well what's the proof of that the other
the other the other thing you yourself
said
hold on we just
showed you the video euron said you
yourself earlier on said and claimed
that the uh the chinese were putting
yugas
yuga muslims included incoming in in uh
education centers
i did not actually that was uh
i called them the radicalization
programs i'm in favor of
de-radicalization are you not
uh not in the sense depends on what it
is i said not in the sense that you kind
of seem to think of it i think it is
and i certainly wouldn't be i certainly
wouldn't be interested if it was a
socialist country doing it because it's
uh it turns into something you see of
john
george orwell so no i'm not so we've
established that i'm a socialist and
you're not
so i don't quite know what the relevance
of that is
i'm asking you
[Music]
you'll never criticize a fellow
socialist country who's committing out
basically the crimes the uh the crimes
against i keep saying that but you
haven't given me any
evidence your argument is you haven't
even
told me are the proof you haven't even
told me because you don't have the guts
to tell me who you're relying on
for this information i'll tell you who
shall i tell me go on al jazeera
nope where where then tell me i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna i'm not gonna pray
why will you not say where you saw
these because people can find this
information out themselves people can
find this information
don't be a gutless colleague don't be a
gutless coward
tell us where you got this information
again coming back to it as a socialist
country
you've never ever seen anything against
china no
actually that's not true i have many
criticisms
of china not about its socialism but
about its capitalism
i have many criticisms of china but
i hate islamist fanaticism
of the kind that cuts people's heads off
and eats their hearts
all over the world i'm not actually
altogether sure
that everyone that is in this
conversation
is with me on that but what i will say
finally if you don't have the guts
to tell us where you got the information
that china is committing crimes against
humanity
i'm going to say that for me you're not
to be
relied upon now brian is in fight
he says he invented facebook
this could be lively go ahead brian good
evening george i hope you're doing well
i'm a fellow scot so i'm sure you will
agree that scots invent the television
and the telephone and discovered
penicillin so we invented we did on the
steam engine
and tim berners-lee is the person that
invented the world wide web
as a science laboratory in switzerland
cern and is he scottish
no he's english okay but
the sister laboratory is where i worked
in
oxford called the rutherford appleton
laboratory we had the first web server
in the united kingdom as you can imagine
we were linked we got it early
what year would that be 1992
wow so for five years
i was researching various bits of the
web how to use it what it could be doing
how we how we inform a business
so that they could take that technology
and do what you're doing now
that you're sitting in a london studio
you're broadcasting to the world you're
on twitter
twitch facebook uh
all of these platforms you're
broadcasting using the technology
and i developed a facebook
website in 1998 by the student mark
zuckerberg
did it six years later wow and not only
did he
come up with a better system than mine
he went for students
i went for adults who did not trust the
web and wouldn't put their information
on we could have had a mac
facebook and you could have been
speaking to me now
as a billionaire yes but unfortunately
i'm autistic
and i struggle to communicate with
humans as you can imagine
you're communicating fine on this thank
you
uh you're you're you're very polite no
you're communicating
fine uh but let me just ask you brian
um now that we're 20 years into it all
uh is it i mean how overwhelmingly
positive
is it i think it's an axiom that it's
overwhelmingly
a positive thing the internet but how
much on a scale of one to ten i mean
is it eight out of ten or nine or only
six
i would say six but the biggest problem
is people do not understand that a tweet
or a facebook post is publication
yeah and forever forever
yes journalists are very careful they
double source their information and you
know
they are very careful they might well
some of them do brian
some of them indeed but they've been
trained and they know that they've got
to get legal coverage they've got an
editor and they knew if they're in a
court
there are restrictions tommy robertson
got caught and
he went into court listened to it came
out and tweeted
and you were not allowed to publish the
information that was in the court and of
course
he got done for that uh just to let you
know i downloaded
three billion tweets
three billion yes
as you can imagine why did why did you
do that
to help the police wow i built the
police social media system it actually
protected you when you were an mp
really if you ever knew that there were
social media threats
all mps were being scanned on twitter in
case you were threatened
if the queen went anywhere if any
politician senior politician went
anywhere
i would i designed and built the
counterterrorism and a public health
system that scanned twitter for people
making threats so that we could protect
you
so you as an mp were protected and if
there was a credible threat against you
the police would have informed you that
george there's a problem
and you know somebody's made a threat
against you in this area
on twitter they would actually publish
it
wow that is amazing so what are you
doing now brian
uh i'm between jobs at the moment uh but
i have
invented a covered solution and my mp
is i don't know if are you aware of
politics at the moment he was the
vaccine
spokesman for the snp was this your uh
was this your wristband issue that you
called us about
it is indeed i am able to track that
through cctv
and if i mean as you're aware at the
moment you've been vaccinated which is
lovely and
well done thanks but we can't see you
you and 15 million people
have disappeared and out of 60 million
people
there's 15 million we can't see you you
currently could
uh give the vaccine to somebody not the
vaccine you could give
covert to somebody else while you're
protected which is lovely
you're risky you could pass it on it's
not a vaccine that protects you and
stops you ever
no no no that's right it just it just
protects me from
becoming seriously ill or dying yeah yes
now
here's the job if you're an nhs person
when you got vaccinated they give you a
pink sticker that you stick on your blue
nhs badge so
they are using color so that they can
tell who
and if you're in icu at a hospital
and you've got covered to give you a
restaurant red wristband
color is being used you see and
therefore pcpv
can see these colors on the wristbands
and you as a human could see if the
person next to you doesn't have a
wristband
then be careful for you you could spread
it to him he could spread it to you
but if he was waiting i think we can
solve that by just being
careful anyway with everybody uh brian
but it's been fascinating
talking to you thanks very much indeed
uh for that call will
trump begin preparations for a 2024
presidential run
yes 51 no
12 percent ivanka instead
down 2 to 37 still a very very healthy
score more than 3 000 people voted
in that poll and i wonder
if they were in florida can we find that
out
that would be interesting so to do let's
get the news first though
with jamie law
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news at least
50 million people in the uk have had
their first coronavirus jab vaccine
minister nazim sahawi has said
the milestone was reached just over two
months after the first jab was delivered
in britain
on december the 8th it comes after
ministers said the uk was on track to
meet its pledge of offering a vaccine to
everyone
in the top four priority groups by
monday from monday
the vaccine rollout is being expanded to
include over 65s and those deemed
clinically
vulnerable one dose of a covered 19
vaccine gives
67 protection after three weeks a
leading epidemiologist
has said professor tim spector of king's
college london who runs the zoe covert
19 surveillance app said data collected
from 50
000 users vaccinated with either the
pfizer or
oxford astrazeneca jabs showed that one
dose gave 46
protection after two weeks rising to 67
after three to six weeks the app uses
information submitted by
more than four million users across the
world to predict and track coronavirus
infections across the uk
and other countries new zealand's prime
minister jacinda ardern has ordered the
country's biggest city
auckland to go into lockdown after the
discovery of three
new local coronavirus cases the measure
will last
three days and require residents to stay
at home
ardern said the country was going hard
and early
after the cases were identified new
zealand has won widespread praise
for its handling of the pandemic going
months without community
transmission the country with a
population of 5 million has recorded
just over 2
300 cases of covid and just 25 deaths
the measure in auckland require its 1.7
million residents to stay at home except
for essential shopping
and work schools and non-essential shops
will close and
entry in and out of the city is
restricted
a woman who made sexual assault
allegations against scotland's former
first minister alex salmond has claimed
that the hollywood inquiry into the saga
has been more traumatic for her in many
ways than the trial was
the woman was one of nine who gave
evidence against the former first
minister of the high court
last year salmond was cleared of all 13
of the sexual assault charges against
him a committee is now
investigating the scottish government's
handling of the original complaints
against mr salmond the inquiry was
intended to ensure that similar mistakes
were not made
in the future and that women could feel
confident in coming forward with
complaints about alleged
sexual misconduct but the woman told the
bbc that she believed it
descended into a political fight that
made it less likely that other women
would report
any concerns she said the row had
effectively allowed the government to
get away with not being properly
scrutinized
on its procedures a 22 year old indian
climate activist has been arrested after
sharing a document intended to help
farmers protest against new agricultural
laws
disharavi is accused of sedition and
criminal conspiracy the documents she
shared a toolkit
which suggests ways of helping the
farmers was first posted by the
prominent
campaigner greta thundberg ravi a
student and one of the founders of the
indian branch of the fridays for future
climate strike
was arrested by delhi police the
protests now in their third month mark
the biggest challenge
india's prime minister narendra modi has
faced new laws loosen rules around the
sale pricing and storage of farm produce
which have protected india's farmers
from the free market for decades
farmers fear that the new laws will
threaten decades-old concessions
such as assured prices and weaken their
bargaining power leaving them vulnerable
to exploitation by private companies
the modi government has offered to
suspend the laws but the farmers want
them replaced altogether
u.s president joe biden has said his
predecessor donald trump's acquittal for
inciting mob violence is a reminder that
democracy is fragile
seven republicans joined the democrats
and voting to convict
falling short of the two-thirds majority
needed to do so
biden said the charge relating to
trump's role in the capital riot last
month was
not in dispute while seeking to move on
from the process
trump has welcomed his acquittal calling
his impeachment a witch-hunt
in the senate on saturday the trial
ended with a 57-43 vote in favour of
conviction
united arab emirates hope mission has
returned its first picture of mars the
spacecraft entered into an orbit around
the red planet on tuesday
making the uae the first arab nation in
history to have a scientific presence
at earth's near neighbour the first
image will be followed by
many similar views of mars hope was put
into a wide orbit so it could study the
planet's weather and climate systems
which mean
that it will also see the planet's full
disk
and finally it actually happens it would
probably be known as
foreign after boris johnson the uk prime
minister proposed a link between
scotland
and northern ireland his idea was for a
bridge
but now it seems a 25 mile undersea
tunnel is the way forward according to
the secretary of state for scotland
alastair jack reiterated his support for
the link ahead of the expected release
of a study that could kick off a formal
consultation on the idea
he said that he had talked to the prime
minister and that a tunnel
appeared to be the most viable way
forward johnson first backed the idea of
connecting milan in northern ireland to
strana
in scotland when he was foreign
secretary in 2018
but this appears to have fallen out of
favor as too complex and expensive
with a tunnel now seen as the preferred
options
it would be about 25 miles long not far
off the channel tunnel 31 miles and
provide a road and
rail link a report on uk transport
infrastructure by the head of network
rail sir peter hendy is reportedly
imminent and expected to say that the
project
is possible that could kick off a formal
government feasibility study
and that's the latest here on sputnik
news i'm jamie lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
now you i've spoken to you before about
this hate crimes bill that the snp
government are putting through
which explicitly states that even
conversations
in your own home can lead to you being
prosecuted
for hate speech so nicholas baker on
twitter
brilliant i said to my wife i hate the
snp
she said to me i hate the snp too
being law abiding we felt compelled to
report each other
to the police as this could be a hate
crime
please you're nicked we both gulped
and we're being sent down tomorrow you
think i'm making that up
uh okay so over 3000 people voted in
that poll
it's now closed but it was such a good
poll i can't bear
to think of another one because i want
to move swiftly on to
the coronavirus issue the issue of
vaccination the issue of
reopening for example the
for youngest children in scotland my own
uh
are due to go back to school on the 22nd
of this month
in england uh next month
with talk of alfresco dining
in april all sounds wonderfully
tantalizing maybe my morale
is just up because i've been vaccinated
let's hear what the expert
thinks dr ranjit brah nhs consultant
physician and surgeon dr ranjit thanks
uh
tell us uh how you're feeling uh about
the
picture in britain first of all uh this
week
uh there's some grounds for optimism is
there not
george good to be with you thank you
again hey fat choi happy valentine's for
everyone who's out there
um i think for the first time there is
some
cause for optimism um because
i think the the single intervention um
that we have got right um
once we've had access to the vaccination
has been the
vaccination campaign it's not over of
course george i mean if you look around
the world there's 109 million
cases now 2.4 million deaths and in the
uk this week numbers are way down and
it's a
falling far faster than they would have
done um had there not been the
enormous success really of the
vaccination program as we know 15
million people now
have been vaccinated with at least one
shot among the
half a million you know two doses of the
vaccine
um but those second doses will be coming
and we're increasingly aware that that
even
wonder has had a protective effect
particularly after a long period of time
increasing uh over time
and therefore it's important after your
first poster
at least three probably four or five
weeks but after that really even those
most vulnerable people are increasingly
confident coming to see me in hospital
increasingly confident
uh coming to see me in clinic coming for
investigations
uh coming for their operations and
well we're not by any means back to
normal yet because still there are 25
000 uh patients with coronavirus
in the uk's hospitals and that means
fully a quarter of our acute beds are
still occupied
um cases are way way down uh 97
000 this week as opposed to just less
than a month ago we were talking about
close to half a million cases
in a week half a million 400 more than
460 000 cases in a single week
but you know the deaths statistic is
still very high
and you can hardly call it um you know
an endorsement of our government policy
the fact that even now after
this vaccination campaigns are going for
two months that we have had this week
close to five thousand four thousand
eight hundred uh and
forty-five deaths people who have died
due to coronavirus so
you know the good news that we found an
intervention that will make a lasting
difference
allow us to move through this open up
return to normality
but when we look back on this i mean the
government has been promising an inquiry
again it will be really too little too
late but really the government have
absolutely in the first instance
followed they've been true to their
initial word
which was the strategy of herd immunity
protecting the economy as far as they
were able to they weren't able to
because there was a
crisis a global financial crisis
which meant that the economy we know for
the whole year shrank by more than 10
well
for certain quarters we're down 20 and
30 percent and worldwide is going to be
a massive
impact a little impact on
the health and well-being which is not
due to lockdown not due to the
government's response far from it
and we know that the countries that lock
down effectively meaning they
target the virus and isolated
appropriately from the
beginning did very well and will do
relatively well economically
whereas we have done very poorly
economically exacerbated by
our initial poor application of
non-pharmaceutical measures but yes
you know let's let's stay with the
positive let's stay with the valentine's
day theme
we we we do have uh some real hope
looking forward that we can move through
this now george
well it's we're definitely looking at it
in a valentine perspective it's still
not safe
to kiss a stranger but you can uh
definitely now
uh kiss your own wife uh with
uh with a relative uh confidence
that you're not going to kill her uh
i feel a bit like the two guys in the
producers
who fully expect indeed make their
musical
deliberately to lose money only to
discover that it
is a rip-roaring success and they ask
each other
outside the theater where did it all go
right
where did this all go right how come
a government which has so
catastrophically failed at every single
stage of this
uh disastrous year suddenly get it right
on vaccination is that down to the nhs
is it down to the army is it down to
both
well you know you can't um give full
credit
to the government for the technology of
vaccination uh
it's a it's a more than 200 year old
technology but this we've had a
it's been a global problem which has
therefore engaged
the entire health and scientific
community
in trying to find a solution so there's
been huge numbers of people looking for
therapeutics looking for vaccinations
and they've been
a marked success in many different
vaccination programs many different
vaccines available we talked last
week about the sputnik vaccine but also
the astrazeneca also moderna also fisa
many of course the the chinese uh
cyanovac
vaccine in particular so there have been
many successful
vaccines developed i think the cheapest
of those
the easiest distributed of those will
have a massive impact
worldwide and will be given particularly
by china
um and to an extent by oxford astro
astrazeneca
at a low price to uh even even though
the poorest uh countries in the world
which will help
move past this pandemic what the
government has done is used this
emergency to push its agenda which is
very similar to the t-tip
agenda very similar to the t
trans-pacific partnership agenda it's
this concept of
making companies um more powerful if you
like the national governments of giving
transferring huge amounts of money from
state sector
into the private hands of opening up and
deregulating markets
markets for large capital and they have
applied that
very successfully in their own in their
by their own yardstick
during this pandemic that without
scrutiny they have been
making sure they had maximum leverage
maximum power to give out
huge amounts of money in contracts many
of those have been totally unsuccessful
the testing campaign was very poorly run
the number of companies who had never
had any experience as a ppi who were
given
hundreds of millions because they were
connected to the tory party
without scrutiny without any comeback
without
any apparent measures that were able to
take against our government or apply
scrutiny all of these were
you know a devastating failure but you
know in this
one area where huge contracts were able
to be given to
pharmaceutical companies who in the
event did come up with
successful vaccines you know that has
proved the success but i think it's you
know worth reflecting on
um the uh opaque nature
of the covered legislation the way in
which they have managed to
our government that is have managed to
avoid scrutiny avoid even the most
basics of what would have been
considered financial propriety for a
public body
in terms of contracting even within you
know a capitalist system
which is by its nature rigged in favor
of the big players rigged in favor
of the monopolists and this is something
that we have seen this week
matt hancock has announced and made
great fanfare that he thinks now in
the height of a pandemic or as we're
moving out of a pandemic
is the best time to announce the major
structural reorganization of the health
service george
oh my goodness now even the telegraph
this week
has conceded that the sputnik
5 has been an enormous success for
russia and is
an extraordinarily efficacious and
simple
vaccination the chinese five
chinese vaccines are doing rip-roaring
trade at cost price
as you said in poor poor countries that
wouldn't be able to
buy from big pharma
big pharma and big companies
uh are usually effective
the problem is the government have been
giving contracts
to people in some cases like the ferry
companies that were given a ferry
contract
even though they had no ferries some
people got big
big business from the british government
that had
never ever done any of the
tasks that they were now being richly
rewarded
for doing and in some cases then
perhaps unsurprisingly failed to carry
out
this is not the stuff for an enquiry
doctor
this is the stuff for a trial surely
it is george but i think what we're
going to actually see isn't
more of the same uh because the uh
boris johnson and matt hancock both um
have
talked about reversing some of the 2012
health and social care act that was the
act if you recall that essentially
actually removed day-to-day operational
control
of government ministers and transferred
in fact
actual control of the nhs to um so simon
stevens
who was previously an employee um very
senior employee of the
global wing global arm of united health
the largest health care company on earth
and the man who helped tony blair to
introduce pfi
on a massive scale into the
nhs now at the beginning of this
pandemic i don't if you remember boris
johnson in fact made some
quite interesting remarks which was he
was surprised to find out
how little control he and central
government had over the nhs clearly
um you know despite being the prime
minister he hadn't really been following
what his colleagues were up to in a
health sector or he hadn't understood it
but this pandemic has brought it back to
him now what
as we're being told in the press is that
that will be reversed but if you read
the fine print what you see is
not that tendering will stop not that
the internal market
will disappear rather they will get rid
of
the what they said were measures
necessarily to make the internal market
fair so competition regulators
the necessity to put contracts out
general
tender to give different companies the
ability to bid for them rather
we'll see a much more similar process
going on throughout the nhs where
contracts are simply made in an opaque
fashion but because
the health boards in charge of them deem
that to be appropriate
and we've seen a lot of takeovers during
this pandemic of
groups of gps groups of clinicians
by um uh well that if you like the the
um
the ccgs the clinical clinical
commissioning groups who are now the
bodies of gps who control 80 percent of
the 140
billion annual budget of the nhs
these groups are merging with the health
insurance industry
sentine and united health in particular
and what we'll see increasingly is that
they are getting the ability to impose
their governance structures their
decision making
on what procedures you will and won't be
able to have on the nhs
which procedures therefore you will and
won't need supplementary insurance for
um and so in fact what we're seeing
under the slogan of protect the nhs
is quite the opposite and what we're
seeing under the you know the words for
coming from our health minister and our
prime minister that
we're reversing the unpopular decisions
of the
2012 health and social care act what
we're in doing
is in fact strengthening them
reinforcing them but giving them
the same opportunity to simply hand out
massive
contract after massive contract and
overall operational care
ultimately to the health insurance
industry george and so we are witnessing
a massive
acceleration of our privatization of our
health is very worrying indeed
yeah we'll have to return to that in
more depth as a subject
on its own i think but here's a couple
of calls
doc that want to talk with you justin in
minnesota
go ahead justin uh how were you doctor
i'm very well thanks justin good um
my question for you and
i know you're a doctor and all that but
um
what are your views on the world health
organization i see them pushing their
videos
online on youtube all the time and i
personally don't really believe these
are doctors i think these are actors
and uh i uh
i'm i i'm trying to honestly convince a
lot of people not to get
the kovit vaccine because uh i believe
the second
jab is gonna lead to a lot of bad things
come summertime what do you think thanks
justin
uh of course that's not the uh view
of the mother of all talk shows i want
to make quickly clear
uh please doctor uh the first part
particularly on the
world health organization justin thinks
they are
actors yeah i'm afraid i don't know
you've got that idea justin it's not
it's not the case uh so there's lots of
different arms for the world health
organ world health organization
they are the groups of uh medical
associations and nations who come
together
to try and form world health policy and
to identify and address
real world health issues so they've been
around for a very very long time
um they're as old as the united nations
essentially
um but uh they certainly are a genuine
organization that they're their leader
actually dr theodel gabriel jesus
um was promoted and put forward for that
position by your own government in the
united states
but he's actually done a surprisingly
good job during this pandemic
and certainly if you look at the initial
reports of the world health organization
um medics from every country
went to china to the wuhan area when
that covered 2019 was first
developed and it's a report i would
recommend you read i'd recommend
everyone read
makes it absolutely clear um just how
well
china dealt with it also led to a model
that the world health organization put
forward
encouraging other nations to be able to
deal with their pandemic appropriately
and the thing that has really hampered
the united states in particular
was the patchy nature of the health care
response the inequality in the country
and the very poor leadership during that
pandemic
that made them totally unable to respond
um
to the prescriptions and the plans of
the world health organization despite
the fact
that it's the wealthiest nation on earth
and of course the education
and the information that was
disseminated was so confusing so
misleading
um partly because um your leadership
unfortunately were much more interested
in scoring anti-china points
than actually looking after uh the
health of their own
population so just you're totally wrong
i'm afraid
uh but you know you should uh def
the coronavirus has to be taken
seriously but i think you know the
vaccination is a good thing
it will allow us to move through this
and return to something like normal life
when we can get back to normal politics
normal issues there will still be a
great deal of inequality great deal to
do
great deal of challenge for our two
countries and
the world going forward but uh yeah i
can't agree with you on on the nature of
the world health organization
uh eve in idaho go ahead eve
hello uh thank you very much
for this uh great show um
my information uh about
the first shot of the five of my
vaccine is that it is a success
and and george
also testified that it was a success for
him
but my information is not as positive
for the
seven shot of the pfizer vaccine
in fact i heard that some even pfizer is
considering
maybe uh either spacing it more out or
maybe
maybe make it not as strong and and
that's my question
what do you think about the second shot
of the fiverr vaccine
okay good question i i i would have
asked him off
stage myself for that very question go
ahead
doctor thanks so i mean my
um appraisal of the pfizer vaccine is
only based on
the information that is currently
available uh and as we know the fisa
vaccine
was launched on the base of their own
internal trial uh which wasn't fully
published but rather on the first
interim analysis but
all the data we had suggested um on low
numbers in both the wings of the arm who
actually contracted
both both wings of the trial who
actually contracted uh
um kovid during the trial and that
trials
some 33 000 people if memory serves
um however that we suggested there was
an efficacy of 95
with the two dose regimen um and that
was following
uh two doses taken three weeks apart
fires have been very strongly saying
that they don't recommend
a delay with their vaccine between one
shot and two
and it does seem that some trials have
shown that there's probably a 50 percent
efficacy after a single shot
but i haven't seen the data suggest that
the second shot delayed wouldn't be
effective that would be
counter-intuitive one would expect
there to be a suitable boost and
ultimately to reach
a similar degree of efficacy um
after the second shot but what we don't
have uh kind of
or what i haven't seen are the the the
data relating to the entire population
there have been anecdotally and
in my own experience and others um
several people who i know have
contracted uh the coronavirus after a
single dose
particularly soon after a single dose
and it does seem that the efficacy
increases over time so so you know
waiting a month
or a month and a half after your first
dose before you consider yourself to be
in any way protected is likely to be
sensible i would expect after the second
dose for you to
reach those high degrees of efficacy if
indeed the trial in general is
reproducible in the larger community
and i think we probably do need more
information to demonstrate that's the
case but
certainly the the initial information we
have certainly for the astrazeneca
uh is that vaccination does indeed stop
the spread of the virus as well as
giving individual
protection thanks uh for that eve and to
justin also minnesota and idaho
doctor um i'm being flooded
with uh the you look
nothing is as it appears to be at least
to a section of the community
and i am now being flooded with
allegations that this whole thing
is fake that you might you're probably
sitting with a green screen behind you
rather than sitting in your study and
the reason is
the clock that is behind you
you you thought that people were looking
at you but they were looking at your
clock
can i suggest a couple of triple a
batteries
uh would bring that clock up to speed
so that i i didn't buy some batteries
today george i'm sorry i can fit them
like if you want i can show you my
there you go there's the date and time
that's probably that's probably
backwards but uh you know people think
the moon landings were faked people
think
that again you just eat it our
discussion
that should convince them but you never
know
thank you very much indeed dr randy
brown
for joining us on the mother of all talk
shows
a two minute break count them
[Music]
look at these reviews an intermediate
masterpiece no way out a surprise
smash no way out it was shocking
courageous inclusive and i
loved every minute of it no way out
how could this happen the show was lousy
and long and we did everything
wrong where did we go
right christmas came early to
broadcasting this year and guess who
they stuffed in our stocking
george galloway it was so crass and so
crude even murdock would have booed
where did we
go wrong last year a radio star was
reborn on the airwaves the mother of all
talk shows with george galloway
a new show moats extra george galloway
bear knuckle
we predict the new show's name will soon
be up in lights if they can find enough
bulbs
[Music]
we were so enthusiastic to build a set
made out of plastic
if anyone spoke sense well we sent them
out the door
they shouted hurray that socialist on
display
where did we go right when they asked
for one more day
we nearly ran away where did we go
[Music]
the best new program of the decade
george
galloway is a political genius
now they like him
oh we knew it wouldn't sell we broadcast
in israel
it's the end of our career it'll run for
20 years
george galloway and the mother of all
talk shows
join us at the college of knowledge
where there are no tuition fees
just fantastic simon that's brilliant
work where did it all go right
now uh on the us issue the trump issue
tom says ivanka is the next member of
the trump clan who will run for
office as soon as possible
wow nadia says both parties are taking
their country
into very hard times and martin says if
trump runs again he will win
and with two impeachment trials he has
no flies on him
trump is not a problem the problem is
the entrenched elite
has no influence over trump because he
needed no
favor or money from the elite and terry
says
hope he doesn't i'd like to see someone
independent
who doesn't present themselves because
extreme wealth got them there
or a daughtery old fool who spent 50
years on capitol hill
well who could you mean by that and mike
says like amar lotham
trump was the outsider who took on the
establishment
and in their clumsy actions the
democrats have made him
stronger than before so yes he will
stand again let's hear from look
in liverpool about labour go ahead luke
it's like george go to eagle to speak
for your first time just to
just say thanks for all you've been
doing the last few months and few years
you know been a big fan of yourself
can we can we uh call him back because i
can't hear
any of that look hang up and we'll call
you back
let's go to stuart in hastings
on chest feeding go ahead stewart
hello george how are you thank you for
having me on your show welcome sir
thank you um i i totally agree what
you're saying uh previously uh well
earlier on on the show about the whole
thing is madness which it is bad
transmania yeah absolutely it's madness
i mean you know
you know over the years in my life you
know i've seen campaigns
over the years like uh fighting for
their for individual rights and all that
i mean which women fought for 100 years
for the less than perfect place
that they have achieved in our society
and now we've got people trying to
cancel them to negate them
to take away their freedoms that they've
won
absolutely that's right yeah it's trying
to
change the whole thing for their own end
i think it's a dangerous precedent
i don't understand what are their own
ends
i mean i've known trans people perfectly
lovely
people uh who want no trouble all they
want to
is to be treated as uh as they want to
as they feel they should be treated and
i have done that
none of this none of this argument
should be confused with
meanness or wickedness towards trans
people
isn't i actually have the feeling
that the lobby who are
mainly not trans people are actually the
ones responsible for this
yeah go on stroke yeah now i have been
arguing that for quite some time that
the people who are pushing this agenda
are not fully transgender people and you
confirm that in a mate which is true
that's that's
my feeling yeah yeah i think i think i
think there's a wider agenda here which
is a dangerous yeah what do you think it
is
i'll tell you i'm very troubled and i'm
going to ask dr
ranjit uh in coming weeks about this
i'm very very troubled about children
being given
hormone blockers uh to
distract them
i don't see how that fits with the
hippocratic
oath because a child is not
capable of consenting to that
uh so it must be their parents who are
consenting to it and i don't see
how the hippocratic oath of do no harm
can possibly square with that
what do you think stuart all right i
agree with you i think it's right it
doesn't square a death at all it's
it's uh it's crazy and um i do believe
that
there's a wider agenda here like with
this i mean what the agenda is we need
to find out and i'm sure
a man of your abilities will find that
out in the long term i'll try
thanks stuart for that uh compliment and
that call thank you
let's uh hear from luke and liverpool
hope it's a better line go ahead luke
hello george for your name yeah very
good sir go ahead yeah spot on yeah
what i'm talking about really is this
kia stamina he's supposed to be like a
man of
a man of the people um but he's here you
know
he's a qc he's a lord but you know i'm
i'm an enemy called from my dad's big
fan of himself as well
social trade unionist and you know he's
he's a man of the people
apparently he's the one who's going to
put labour forward
i don't know why you think he's a man of
the people uh no no
but um that's not my opinion that's what
the media are saying you know what i
mean that's not my opinion but that
that's what you're told to believe isn't
it george i think very few people
believe it
they said that corbin was holding labar
back
but in fact it turns out corbin was
holding labour up
uh because since since he left
uh they have uh lost by one means or
another
a huge number of their members and their
polling
has gone down not up but down
despite uh over a hundred thousand
people okay the thing about this this
care is
as well i've seen a you know i'll always
back i'm i'm a loyal i i love being
myself a little bit
later man uh sold me dad that's what you
believe in
and i've seen you know we've been
through blair or whatever you've been
through
all the labor but i've seen this pair of
jeans that he established he made
proper bag of baggy pets
let's go to mike let's go to mike
in south carolina go ahead mike
hey george it's great to talk to you
again never miss your show thanks
thanks very much sir i wanted to address
the uh conversation you had with simon
earlier that uh
he seems to think that uh that your only
uh
reason for being there is to grow the
socialist agenda
and uh uh you know he says that you
won't support any you know
like for instance the china uh argument
that he was making uh
and you and i he wouldn't he wouldn't
give
the source of his claim that china was
committing
crimes against humanity and we know the
reason why mike
because the only the only people that
are claiming that
are either television stations
and media outlets that support
the fanatic islamist cause
or the western media outlets
who've never given a damn about muslims
anywhere else in the world
but are suddenly in love with the
muslims of china
absolutely true and and you know the you
can see that he is
he has followed the uh the talking
points about this
and and socialism in and of itself
is is is evident in every country it's
here in the united states it's in the uk
it's all over europe
uh it's just a matter of degree a few
degrees of separation between
uh western countries and china who is
now
you know almost fully capitalist but but
the problem is
uh the chinese are doing capitalism much
better than the united states and
england that's what that's what they
really don't like isn't it it's not the
socialism
in china that they like it's
the capitalism in china is being done
far more successfully oh absolutely
and nothing nothing illustrates that
point better than
uh the uh the row that the western
governments are having with huawei
okay yeah when they actually arrested
the daughter of the ceo of huawei
in canada at the request of the american
government okay
but the fact the matter is that the uh
that huawei
is is a much better company than
the ones that it's already surpassed
it's number one past apple and samsung
and the rest of them in
telecommunications equipment
and and the fact of the matter is uh
huawei the company
is wholly owned by the employees
the the ceo of huawei only has a one
percent
share of huawei the rest of it is owned
by the employees and we can
i'm glad you made that point i had
forgotten it uh
and you're absolutely correct we have
such places
here not many uh but one of the
finest stores in the country
uh is the john lewis partnership
which is jointly owned by all the
employees
the they have a grosser
grocery arm also which is uh owned by
the employees
this kind of thing mustn't be allowed to
catch on mike
that's exactly right because you know
that would take all that money away from
these people
that uh are running everything well done
great call thanks for
ian is in hounslow on china go ahead ian
hello george hi um it's just about this
western propaganda blitz against the
people's republic of china yeah i mean
no nation is completely innocent
no nation is completely blemished free
but the way they're going on
anyone would think we hadn't laid waste
to all those countries in the middle
east surrounding israel
in the name in the name of crushing
militant islam well the worst one of
course is yemen who've done nothing to
nobody
exactly that is a real crime and we've
got
shotgun djs or right wing neo liberal
stations
pouring out these propaganda and when i
try to call
they're called screening they won't even
let you
put a question to them
what you've said there is absolutely
blindingly true
that we have fought war after war after
war against what we say we're fighting
uh extremist muslims
extremist muslim leaders
china puts extremist muslims
in a de-radicalization center
or camp call it what you will and
suddenly all the people that supported
all the wars against the muslim
countries around the world
are throwing their hands up in horror
about what's happening in china
and useful idiots like simon if that's
his name
uh who called up earlier like pavlov's
dogs go running after them
these camps these camps are they called
abu grave and camp delta
is that what they're called or
guantanamo bay
exactly now look at hong kong look at
the restraints
the chinese police held against what
were rioters
not armed by the way they're not
you're not even armed in america they
shot people i didn't see them shooting
anybody in hong kong did you
no but i saw i saw demonstrators
setting fire to uh people who are
supporting the police
i did see that ian thanks for the call
the hour is late must press on
dale is in surrey on china
go ahead dale oh hi uh george nice to be
on the show again
and you sir um so um
i just wanted to ask about your opinion
i'm surprised you didn't mention it
because i follow your twitter feed
quite a lot but about the um uh china
banning bbc world service i mean
i did mention on twitter i predicted it
yeah
i mean it's just astounding hypocrisy
though because cgtn was banned literally
a couple of days before
exactly yeah and now they're saying that
um
china's curtailing media freedom i mean
that's the pot calling the kettle black
surely well
it shows you the capacity these people
have for lying
they are attacking china for closing the
bbc in china
when they just closed the chinese main
broadcasting entity
cgtn a week earlier
but they hope that you don't know that
or that you don't connect these two
things
i mean the way the ease dale
the ease with which these people can lie
can dissemble can distort
and deceive is actually truly remarkable
the there are bbc people with straight
faces
lamenting the closure of bbc world
in china when they know it is a
direct response to the british
state regulator ofcom
closing down chinese tv one week before
it's like they have to find some way to
criticize china or russia i don't know
if you
um saw the latest news now um apparently
um elon musk
wants to meet with uh vladimir putin i
did see that i
i advise uh president putin to meet uh
elon musk um he's a big player
in business uh it's i was surprised to
see
the invitation but why shouldn't he
accept it dale
i'm ready to talk to anyone aren't you
absolutely i mean
what what level of criticism do you
think elon musk will now face
well that is a good point that is a very
good point
i hadn't thought of that very good
indeed dale thanks for that
let's go to graham in ayrshire on
transmania go ahead graham hi george i
was indeed going to talk to you about
transmania and
i was also going to talk about covert
19. i'm kind of protecting i might not
have time for both
and if you're if you're quick go ahead
oh
okay i'll try my best um but i just want
to thank you first of all for raising
this because it is an important issue
and it's one that a lot of people are
scared to to talk about and that's
really the reason i'm calling um first
of all just to reinforce that more
people should be talking about because
it's not just
the words that are being used it's
important these are
world implications as well at the moment
we're seeing
obviously we're seeing males in women's
sports fighting in the olympics
um or in things like weightlifting it's
obscene we're seeing
australian footballers um
you know playing against women we're
seeing fallen fox and mixed martial arts
um transitioning male to female
now fighting against women in the steel
cage all these things are obscene
um we're also seeing women not just
having their identity array
raised but that's making it difficult
for them to fight for their rights as
well because
women's rights uh women's oppression
isn't just based on their gender
identity
it's based on their biology and i think
that's
something we need to recognize um if we
would
want to tackle this uh the issue of
women's oppression as well
um that's just wonderful we will we will
return to that
uh subject graham i'm sure uh go ahead
to your second point
please um yeah i'm sorry i can just
there's one little thing on the
transmania
yeah i wanted to speak speak to people
on the left here because i'm a leftist
myself
very far now after the matter of fact so
i i don't come from
any sort of bigoted perspective i
believe people should have rights to
work to access all services regardless
of how they identify or
who they want to sleep with anything
that's absolutely up to them
and i just wanted to appeal to those in
the left who are confused by this
issue um because many are seeing the
conflation between homophobia and
transphobia and
the last thing they want to do is be
seen as a bigot
and so i thought maybe it would help to
give people the confidence to speak
out by just raising a couple of
definitions if that's all right
when we're talking about sex what we're
really talking about is a biological
construct
and if we understand this definition i
think it makes
the whole topic easier to understand now
everyone knows
uh at least until five years ago
everyone knew what sex was
it's a descriptor of your reproductive
capacity
so that's something that's binary males
um the members of the species whether
it's humans
birds cats lions whatever they're the
ones that produce spermatozoa garment
and that's the the garment that
fertilizes with ova to create zygotes in
other words you need these
two different sexes to produce to
reproduce
um so if you understand that the
question of
trans women that it is quite clear a
trans woman
is a male they're born male with the
with the capacity to produce the
spermatoa um they will never be able to
produce over
so they will always be male
and i think if you grasp that it becomes
easier to stand up and call down
i can't let you go on to the other issue
graham because of the hour
uh but you've made a very powerful point
on that
men are men and women are women uh
just by encanting as an earlier
texter did that trans women are women
does not make them so any more than me
defining myself declaring myself as
sir marcus rashford makes me sir marcus
rashford it says
binary as that graham and ershad thanks
great call i'll be a lot in airshire
over the next few weeks graham maybe
we'll meet
richard is in manchester and
uh he may be the last call no we might
get another one in
richard go ahead
richard are you there yes can you hear
me george
very clearly no thank you go ahead sir
uh
george uh the thing i want to ask about
um is
uh this tape about the killing of kelly
which uh is coming out in a little while
how long is it going to be please
uh it's uh a 90-minute feature
uh it will although there will be
different versions of it
because if we can persuade television
station
to uh to air it then 90 minutes will be
too long for most of those and we hope
to negotiate television
coverage of it to reach the maximum
audience so there'll be
a director's cut and there'll be uh the
commercially available
uh option but the film will be out in
april richard that can be pre-ordered
actually at my
shop at georgetown shop and a lot of
people have already pre-ordered it and
many have ordered the uh very nice
brilliant actually cinema poster
uh which we sign and send off to
people so anticipation is building
richard great job it's building up here
in manchester with all the people who
are interested what we're done at that
stage
uh can i just take up um a little one
george about uh
last last week i got hold of the uh
scottish herald
and uh i i contributed to that for a
couple of months to give me an insight a
closer insight
would it been from the scots um into
what was happening uh with the salmon
the
salmon affair with sturgeon yeah and uh
i got quite into it uh on
the 11th it was and uh you know the
section where it comes up
comments and people actually asking uh
different questions and then
somebody else would give an answer and
then it would go on and so on
um who came up on it but uh alistair
campbell
all right so i yes and i got involved in
this
and i i i sort of put on that what what
why are you getting
involved in this what's it got to do
with you because
lots of people have been commenting
about the nastiness of
a sturgeon and what's going on with her
mps and so on
and they've been casting aspersions as
to who's been uh sort of advising her
over the last six months it's got worse
and worse
anyway well that's very interesting i
wonder if it might be aleister campbell
that would certainly explain a thing or
two
uh richard uh from my point of view
and uh i declare an interest i know
alex almond exceedingly well i sat in
parliament with them for more than 20
years
i watched you yeah i'm wholly against
his uh
uh his campaign for separatism
uh but he is not
as he was painted he
was always going to be acquitted as i
predicted
in advance at the time he was an
innocent man who was set up
by people in his own party
imagine i fully agree with that and
anybody who can stoop solo
to try to get a man what it would have
been i think at the end of the day
would be a life sentence for him and uh
anybody who could do that
needs watching very very carefully i
think you've put that brilliantly
anybody that can do that wants watching
very carefully richard thanks uh for a
wonderful call
let's hear from breed in ireland go
ahead breed
yeah hi george happy valentine's day
thank you very much um are you doing a
trojan work to keep britain together
george and as you've just been saying
you're resisting scottish independence
hugely
um and you're doing trojan work about
that but also in the past you know you
said that you sort of believe in our is
humilification
i'm just wondering how you um if your
excitement around the proposed tunnel
between throne rare and lauren has
something to do with sympathy for
northern irish loyalists
and um unionists these days seeing as
they're related
it has nothing to do with that my views
on ireland are well known and lifelong
uh and if you think about it are
entirely um
in keeping with my views about britain
i don't agree with partitioning
small islands i believe in unifying
countries not
breaking them up and so from my point of
view there's no
contradiction in these two things at all
uh
either the people of northern ireland
will vote
to reunify or they will not that's a
matter
for them it's laid out in the good
friday agreement
they have the right to a border pole
and when that border poll is held i
don't know when it will be
it will either agree to reunification or
it will
agree to the status quo
either way having this tunnel
is a very good idea if
the north voted for reunification
if it did it would be
of solace to the people in northern
ireland who identify as british
that there was a physical connection to
britain
i'd go further and say that in those of
in those circumstances
those who wanted to keep their british
nationality
but continue to live in ireland ought to
be accommodated
so that they could be bi-nationals and
so on
if on the other hand the people in the
north
decide they want to remain in britain
then it goes without saying
that they will be far more closely
connected
if this tunnel exists but my main reason
breed is for jobs in the south of
scotland
i want to see a 10 billion pound
public investment in construction in
engineering
in the road works in the rail works i
want to see employment
in my own area picked up off the ground
and set to work that's my main reason
and i believe it will be to the economic
as well
as the cultural and other tourists and
so on
uh benefit of both ireland and scotland
last word to you
yeah that's a very logical amber and
understandable
george um finally do you think that um
the protocol is very difficult for
unionists to swallow
and what advice would you have for the
dep at this point
i never give advice to the dup
in public uh at 21 57
and 25 seconds i don't have time in
other words to do so
call me again and we might get on to
that
because you've got a legend on the line
it's norma
in bristol norma how wonderful go ahead
hello there's never much time george so
i'm cutting it
short yeah um valentine's day
now my thrill of the day was next door
suddenly there was this loud music
outside
bob marley one love blaring out
so we went outside to see the spectacle
now her man
proposed to my lovely neighbor next door
and they've both been in their marriage
before and they're in their 40s
and she accepted and we all sang this
great big bob
marley when love's wrong together
totally wonderful this happened
today today yeah today because it's
valentine's day
it was a lovely surprise george it
really was
that is fantastic and what a great
choice of song
oh yes it's wonderful that
still in 2021 under pressure
from all kinds of things new ideas
and economic and health challenges
men are still going down on one knee and
asking women
to marry them don't you think that's
great oh it was lovely george but my
own romantic moment is i my fault
my two teeth fell out so i'm speaking
funny
because i've taken i've just got some
falsies now that is so unromantic
at my age but that's my body i'm sure
that your husband will kiss you just as
sweetly
as ever without your two front teeth
it's been marvelous for me if it was for
you
come back next week same time same place
good night
[Music]
you